Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. Whoa! Is that the new Kia Sportage? Yeah, I just got it. I love the updated styling and the distinctive LED lighting. And check this out. No key needed with digital key on my phone. Oh.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。重复一遍，therestishistory.com。哇！那是新款起亚 Sportage 吗？对，我刚买的。我很喜欢它更新的造型和独特的 LED 灯光。你看这个。用我手机上的数字钥匙，连钥匙都不用了。哦。
And I can check it remotely on the Kia Connect app. I heard it also comes in a hybrid and a plug-in hybrid. It does, with a quiet ride and unbelievable fuel economy. The new Kia Sportage is here. Visit Kia.ca to learn more. Kia, movement that inspires. From commutes that become learning sessions to dishwashing filled with laughs, podcasts can help you make the most out of your everyday. And when it comes to everyday spending, you
而且我可以在起亚互联 (Kia Connect) 应用程序上远程查看它。我听说它还有混动和插电混动版本。确实有，驾驶安静，油耗低得惊人。全新起亚 Sportage 现已登场。访问 Kia.ca 了解更多详情。起亚，灵感随行。从变成学习时间的通勤，到充满欢笑的洗碗时光，播客能帮你充分利用每一天。而说到日常消费，你可以
can count on the PC Insider's World Elite MasterCard to help you earn the most PC optimum points everywhere you shop. The PC Insider's World Elite MasterCard, the card for living unlimited. Conditions apply to all benefits. Visit pcfinancial.ca for details. When does fast grocery delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without the grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit, but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that, actually, they will stay for dinner.
信赖 PC Insider's World Elite 万事达卡，它能帮你你在每次购物时赚取最多的 PC Optimum 积分。PC Insider's World Elite 万事达卡，开启无限生活的信用卡。所有优惠均受条款约束。访问 pcfinancial.ca 了解详情。什么时候通过 Instacart 快速配送杂货最重要？当你著名的颗粒芥末土豆沙拉没有了颗粒芥末就不那么著名的时候。当烧烤已经点燃，却没有什么可烤的时候。当亲家突然决定，实际上他们要留下来吃晚饭的时候。
Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer. So download the app and get delivery in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus, enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees exclusions and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] Dinner was prepared in a spacious hall. Several small tables were placed in the middle of the hall for the newly married couple and the rest of the dwarfs, who were all splendidly dressed after the German fashion. After dinner, the dwarfs began to dance after the Russian way, which lasted
今年夏天，Instacart 为你的所有杂货保驾护航。赶快下载应用程序，享受最快 60 分钟送达服务。此外，前三单还可享受 0 元配送费。服务费、排除项和条款适用。Instacart，超值配送的杂货服务。["星条旗之歌"] 晚餐在一个宽敞的大厅里准备着。大厅中央摆放着几张小桌子，供新婚夫妇和其余的侏儒们使用，他们都穿着华丽的德国时尚服装。晚餐后，侏儒们开始跳起俄罗斯风格的舞蹈，这持续到了
till eleven at night. It is easy to imagine how much the Tsar and the rest of the company were delighted at the comical capers, strange grimaces, and odd postures of that medley of pygmies, most of whom were so short that their size alone had people in fits of laughter. One had a high hunch on his back and very short legs, another was remarkable by a monstrous big belly. A third came waddling along on a little pair of crooked legs like a badger. A fourth had head of prodigious size. Some had
深夜十一点。不难想象沙皇和其余的宾客对这群侏儒滑稽的跳跃、奇怪的做作和古怪的姿势感到多么高兴，他们大多数人都太矮了，仅凭身材就让人笑得前仰后合。一个人背上有个高高的驼背，腿很短，另一个人则以一个硕大无比的肚子引人注目。第三个人迈着一双像獾一样弯曲的小短腿蹒跚走来。第四个人有着一颗巨大的脑袋。有些人
wry mouths and long ears, little pig eyes and chubby cheeks, and there were many more such comical figures. When these diversions were ended, the newly married couple were carried to the sars house and bedded in his own bed chamber. So that was Friedrich Christian Weber, who was the ambassador of Hanover, the German state to the court of Peter the Great. And he is struggling to cope, I guess, Dominic with the fondness for grotesquery that has been a marker of Peter's court right from the very beginning. And Weber there is describing a wedding feast that was held in St. Petersburg in November 1710, where the couple and all the attendees were dwarves. And And all the attendees were dwarfs.
歪嘴长耳，猪小眼红扑扑的脸蛋，还有更多这样滑稽的人物。这些消遣结束后，新婚夫妇被抬到沙皇的房子里，并安顿在他的私人卧室里。所以那是弗里德里希·克里斯蒂安·韦伯，他是汉诺威（德国的一个州）派往彼得大帝宫廷的大使。我猜，多米尼克，他一直在努力应付彼得宫廷从一开始就有的对怪诞的喜爱。韦伯在那里描述的是 1710 年 11 月在圣彼得堡举行的一场婚礼，那对夫妇和所有出席者都是侏儒。而且 而且所有出席者都是侏儒。
And it's very expressive of Peter's kind of dark sense of humor. His fondness for, I suppose, making a show of people who aren't of normal size. I mean, he's obsessed by giants as well as dwarfs, isn't he? He is. And there are German princes who are obsessed by giants, for instance. But Peter's obsession with that kind of grotesquery seems exceptional even by the standards of the time. I think that's right, Tom, and we'll be unpacking that a little bit in the first half of today's episode.
这非常体现彼得那种黑暗的幽默感。他对，我想，展示那些身材不正常的人有一种偏爱。我的意思是，他对巨人和侏儒都很着迷，不是吗？他是。而且有些德国诸侯也对巨人着迷，例如。但彼得对这种怪诞的痴迷，即使以当时的标准来看也显得非同寻常。我认为那是对的，汤姆，我们将在今天这一集的上半部分对此进行一点剖析。
So people who've been with us since the very beginning of this Peter the Great epic will know that we've had lots of war, lots of diplomacy and battles. We had the Great Northern War, we had Charles XII's rise and fall. We had the Battle of Poltava and Russia's ascent to join the ranks of the great powers. And in this final episode, we'll look at the last years of Peter's life and above all, the terrible and tragic story of what happens to his son, Alexis, and there will, yes, be some misconduct with dwarves to come. But the reason we started with that guy, Friedrich Christian Weber, and his reaction to the
所以，从这场彼得大帝史诗一开始就一直陪伴我们的朋友们会知道，我们经历了很多战争、很多外交和战役。我们有过大北方战争，有过查理十二世的崛起与衰落。我们有过波尔塔瓦战役以及俄罗斯跻身大国行列的崛起。在最后一集中，我们将回顾彼得生前的最后几年，最重要的是，他的儿子阿列克谢身上发生了什么可怕而悲惨的故事，当然，接下来还会有一些对侏儒的不当行为。但我们之所以从那个叫弗里德里希·克里斯蒂安·韦伯的家伙以及他对
wedding feast is because he's a nice guide to what St. Petersburg, what Russia would have felt like to a visitor from the West. And he hadn't actually seen that wedding, had he? No. So clearly it is something that is circulating among ambassadors in St. Petersburg as an example of the kind of the madness of the SARS court. Exactly, because that wedding was at the end of 1710 and four years later when he arrived in 1714, the diplomatic corps are still talking about it as a sign of how weird and outlandish
这场婚礼的反应开始，是因为他是一个很好的向导，能让我们了解圣彼得堡和俄罗斯对于一个西方访客来说会是什么感觉。而且他实际上并没有看过那场婚礼，对吧？没有。所以很明显，这是在圣彼得堡的外交官中间流传的一件事，作为沙皇宫廷那种疯狂的一种例子。确切地说，因为那场婚礼是在 1710 年底，而四年后，当他在 1714 年抵达时，外交使团仍然在谈论它，以此作为彼得的宫廷是多么诡异、奇特
and extravagant Peter's court is. So when he actually arrived Weber in St. Petersburg, he finds it still a building site. So we talked in a previous episode about how the land was captured from the Swedes in 1703. Peter began work on the fortress and they had these gigantic teams of conscript laborers who were all being carried off by scurvy or malaria and whatnot. What did you call it Thomas? City built on bones. Yeah, that's the famous description of it. Yeah,
和穷奢极欲的标志。所以当韦伯真正抵达圣彼得堡时，他发现这里仍然是一个建筑工地。所以我们在之前的一集里讨论过这片土地是如何在 1703 年从瑞典人手中夺取的。彼得开始建造堡垒，他们有这些庞大的服劳役的劳工队伍，他们都被坏血病或疟疾等疾病夺去了生命。你叫它什么来着，托马斯？建立在骨头上的城市。对，那是对它的著名描述。是的，
but by the 1710s, so moving forward 10 years or so, Peter's sort of, if you went into his papers, they are full of kind of specs and plans for churches and palaces and offices and canals and things. By 1712, he's effectively moved the capital to St Petersburg, even though it's not finished. The census claims there are tens of thousands of buildings. I think that might be a bit exaggerated, but by 1716 or so, he's got an Italian guy called Domenico Trezzino, who's building up a grid of canals. And he's got a guy called a Frenchman called Jean Baptiste Alexandre LeBlanc, who draws up a street network on a very enlightenment, rationalist ordered plan.
但到了 1710 年代，也就是向前推进了 10 年左右，彼得的——如果你去查阅他的文件，它们到处都是关于教堂、宫殿、办公室、运河等的规格说明和计划。到 1712 年，他实际上已经将首都迁到了圣彼得堡，尽管它还没有完工。人口普查声称有数万座建筑。我认为这可能有点夸张，但到 1716 年左右，他找了一个名叫多梅尼科·特雷齐尼的意大利人来建造运河网。他还找了一个名叫让-巴蒂斯特·亚历山大·勒布朗的法国人，按照非常启蒙运动的、理性的、有序的计划绘制了街道网络。
Because there are a network of canals. And so St. Petersburg is one of the many cities that have been described as the Venice of the north, I think much more reasonably than say, Birmingham, with no disrespect to my father's native city. Yeah. But the setting of St. Petersburg, which when it is begun, seems mad. It's a marsh, it's a bog, there are kind of vast waters. Once Peter has succeeded in imposing his order on it, raised up on the bones of all the laborers, but this sense of a kind of Augustan order bones of all the laborers, but this sense of a kind of Augustan order emerging amid what had been bogs.
因为这里有一个运河网络。因此，圣彼得堡是被描述为北方威尼斯 的众多城市之一，我认为这比比如说伯明翰要合理得多，对我的家乡城市没有不敬的意思。是的。但圣彼得堡的环境，当它开始时，看起来是疯狂的。它是一个沼泽，它是一个泥潭，有着广阔的水域。一旦彼得成功地将他的秩序强加于其上，在所有劳工的白骨之上拔地而起，但这种在一片泥潭中涌现出的某种奥古斯都式的秩序感劳工的白骨之上拔地而起，但这种在一片泥潭中涌现出的某种奥古斯都式的秩序感
The result is one of the most spectacular cityscapes of all time. I mean, St. Petersburg is a stunningly beautiful city in large part because of the combination of these 18th century buildings with the vastness of the river. Yeah. I mean, it's an amazing place to visit. Yeah. I agree with you completely. It is a remarkable place.
其结果是有史以来最壮观的城市景观之一。我的意思是，圣彼得堡是一个惊艳美丽的城市，很大程度上是因为这些 18 世纪的建筑与河流的浩瀚完美结合。我的意思是，这是一个令人惊叹的旅游胜地。是的。我完全同意你的看法。这是一个非凡的地方。
There's no, we're quite like him in the world. And yet the interesting thing is it's meant to be the window on the West. It's meant to be a model of European modernity of rationalism. You know, it's sort of anticipating so many of the themes of the enlightenment. And yet this guy, Weber, the guy who you began with that reading, what struck him when he arrived in St. Petersburg was not how European it was. It was actually how non-European. So at the very first public function he went to, he commented on what he called the foul language and the rudeness of the guards. And he was
世界上没有哪个地方像它一样。然而有趣的是，它本意是通往西方的窗口。它本意是欧洲现代性、理性的典范。你知道，它某种程度上预示了启蒙运动的那么多主题。然而这个叫韦伯的家伙，也就是你用他的朗读开篇的那个家伙，当他抵达圣彼得堡时，震惊他的不是它有多么欧洲化。实际上是它有多么非欧洲化。所以在参加的第一个公共活动上，他评论了他所谓的粗言秽语和卫兵的粗鲁。并且他
really struck by the fact that he was dressed quite modestly. He realized that everybody else was dressed in what he called trimmed with gold and silver. In other words, what Russians wanted, what they were rewarded and valued was not modesty and humility but bling basically. So when he turns up the guards refused to accept that he's an ambassador don't they? And he says well well, I'm from Hanover. And they say, I've never heard of it. Yes. They're ostentatiously rude to him.
真的对这样一个事实感到震惊：他自己穿得相当朴素。他意识到其他所有人穿的都是他所谓的镶金嵌银的衣服。换句话说，俄罗斯人想要的、他们所奖励和重视的不是谦逊和低调，基本上就是珠光宝气。所以当他出现时，卫兵拒绝接受他是大使，对吧？他说，我，我来自汉诺威。他们说，我从来没听说过。是的。他们对他粗鲁无礼。
Yeah. And that combination of, um, suspicion of the West, but also the obsession with extravagance and bling as a marker of status, I mean, that would be very familiar to anybody who's visited Russia since the 1990s. I mean, that's effectively the vibe in, in Moscow or St. Petersburg now also a constant of Russian history is the drinking. So Weber couldn't believe how much people drank. He said, I drank a dozen glasses of Hungarian wine at this function. And then federal Romanovsky, the mock czar came up and said to him, I want
是的。而这种对西方的怀疑，以及对奢侈和珠光宝气作为身份标志的痴迷的结合，对于任何自 1990 年代以来访问过俄罗斯的人来说都会非常熟悉。我的意思是，这实际上就是现在莫斯科或圣彼得堡的氛围。俄罗斯历史的另一个常态就是酗酒。所以韦伯简直不敢相信人们喝了多少酒。他说，在这个活动上我喝了十几杯匈牙利葡萄酒。然后费奥多尔·罗曼诺夫斯基，那个假沙皇走过来对他说，我想要
you to drink a full port of brandy. What's Romanovsky has a history of getting a bear to strip you. If you don't drink all this. Yeah. And Weber said, you know, I lost my senses, although I had the comfort to observe that the rest of the guests lying asleep on the floor were in no condition to make reflections at my little skill in drinking. Which kind of gives you a sense of exactly what is expected of you.
你喝下一整品脱白兰地。罗曼诺夫斯基有找一头熊来剥光你衣服的历史，如果你不把这些都喝完的话。是的。韦伯说，你知道，我失去了知觉，虽然我感到安慰的是，其余躺在地板上睡着的客人们也没有状态来对我的微末酒量评头论足。这某种程度上让你对别人对你的期望有了确切的了解。
If you turn up as a diplomat, you basically have to put on gold robes and just start drinking brandy. A couple of other things that caught his eye, he noticed that people were wearing the latest fashions, so French-hooped petticoats, he said, so that a visitor might think he was in London or Paris. So Peter has won that battle with the elite to get them to wear the latest Western fashions. But it's interesting he name checks petticoats because the women, as we said, are much more enthusiastic about Western fashions than the men tend to be, perhaps because men are required
如果你作为一个外交官出现，你基本上就得穿上金袍子然后开始狂饮白兰地。还有几件事吸引了他的眼球，他注意到人们穿着最新的时尚服装，比如法国式裙撑衬裙，他说，以至于一个访客可能会以为自己身在伦敦或巴黎。所以彼得赢得了与精英阶层的这场战斗，让他们穿上了最新的西方时尚。但有趣的是，他特意提到了衬裙，因为正如我们所说，女性比男性要热情得多，对西方时尚更感兴趣，也许是因为男性需要
to bear stockinged calves and it's chillier, isn't it, in the dead of winter? Yeah, I guess that's probably true. But what also really strikes him, you know, this is not an ordinary European court. His description is a little bit like a man who's gone to a kind of a gathering of the intergalactic federation or something. And there are kind of aliens there because he's really astonished by the sight of Uzbeks or Kalmyks with turbans and long robes, their envoys from the courts further east or people bringing gifts of Chinese silk and Persian cloth. In other words, his description is a perfect example of that common
露出穿袜子的罗圈腿，而且在严冬时节天气更冷，对吧？是的，我想那大概是真的。但真正让他大吃一惊的是，（你知道，这不是一个普通的欧洲宫廷。）他的描述有点像一个去参加某种星际联邦集会的人。那里有些类似外星人之类的人，因为他对看到乌兹别克人或卡尔穆克人戴着头巾穿着长袍感到非常震惊，他们是来自更东方宫廷的使节，或者是带着中国丝绸和波斯织物礼物的人。换句话说，他的描述是俄罗斯作为欧洲与亚洲、东方与西方十字路口的常见
cliche of Russia as the crossroads of kind of Europe and Asia, East and West. But also as a kind of showcase for exoticism. Yes. And this is an age when Europeans in the West are increasingly alert to the exotic nature of the Orient, and so it's amazing for them to find it on the shores of the Baltic. Exactly. And this, so the fascination with exoticism, this is kind of where the dwarves come in. Now dwarves are part of the formula of any European court in the late 17th, early 18th
陈词滥调的一个完美例子。但同时也是某种异国情调的展示橱窗。是的。这是一个西方的欧洲人越来越警觉于东方异国情调的时代，所以能在波罗的海岸边发现它，对他们来说太神奇了。确切地说。所以，对异国情调的迷恋，这就是侏儒登场的地方。现在侏儒是 17 世纪末、18 世纪初任何欧洲宫廷规程的一部分
century. So most European monarchs will have dwarves on hand. If you think of Diego Bellasquez's great painting Las Meninas, painted about 50 years before this, obviously that's all about the dwarves at the Spanish court. And Dominic, also just to reiterate that it is also about giants. The king of Prussia with his regiments of giants. And Peter has a giant, doesn't he? A Frenchman called Nicolas Bourgeois, who's seven foot two inches, who he'd picked up in Calais. And he's so keen
。所以大多数欧洲君主身边都会有侏儒。如果你想想迭戈·委拉斯开兹的大作《宫娥》，大约在这之前 50 年画的，显然那全关于西班牙宫廷的侏儒。多米尼克，也要重申一下，这也关于巨人。普鲁士国王拥有他的巨人团。而彼得有一个巨人，对吧？一个名叫尼古拉斯·布尔茹瓦的法国人，身高七尺二寸，是他在加来发现的。他非常热衷于
on this, he marries Bourgeois to a Finnish giantess that he's found in the hope that they will breed a race of giants. But unfortunately, they don't have children. There is something unusual about Peter. He has an absolute fixation on this. He would go to church with an escort of dwarves. He always had dwarf acrobats and jesters on hand. And he was very keen on having dwarfs hiding inside pies
这一点，他把布尔茹瓦嫁给了一个他在芬兰发现的女巨人，希望能培育出一个巨人族。但不幸的是，他们没有孩子。彼得身上有一些不同寻常的地方。他对这一点有一种绝对的执念。他去教堂时会有一队侏儒护送。他身边总是带着侏儒杂耍演员和小丑。而且他非常热衷于让侏儒藏在馅饼里
Yes, of course. They're always kind of bursting out of pies, aren't they? So we were talking about this old family yesterday You presumably can't bake the pie with the dwarf already inside But how do you then insert the dwarf into the pie without making a hole in the crust you make the the content of the pie? Yeah on a huge scale and a pie dish Vast pie dish. Yeah. And then you have raised pastry. So the dwarf crouches down and you raise the pastry over the dwarf and then he bursts out. But surely the pie is hot or these cold pies is more like a quiche.
没错，当然。他们总是从馅饼里跳出来，对吧？所以我们昨天还在讨论这个老家族。你大概不能把侏儒已经塞在里面去烤这个馅饼吧？但是你怎么能在不破坏外壳的情况下把侏儒塞进馅饼里呢？你把馅饼的内容物做成巨大规模，用一个巨大的馅饼盘。巨大馅饼盘。是的。然后你用发面面团。所以侏儒蹲下来，你在侏儒身上提起面团，然后他从里面跳出来。但馅饼肯定是热的，或者这些是冷馅饼，更像乳蛋饼？
Yes, a quiche, I guess. Okay. Theo says you put the top on last. So he agrees with you. Yeah. Well, anyway, I think there's a slight political meaning to this though. All his life, Peter has liked undermining the seriousness and piety of Orthodox Moscow, going right back to the days with the
是的，乳蛋饼，我猜。好的。西奥说你最后才把顶部盖上。所以他同意你的观点。是的。无论如何，我认为这背后有一点政治含义。彼得一生都喜欢破坏东正教莫斯科的严肃和虔诚，一直追溯到
revolt of the Streltsy and all that stuff. And that dwarf wedding that we opened with came two days after his niece Anne had married the Duke of Courland. And I think the dwarf wedding was clearly a self-conscious parody of the wedding that had happened two days earlier. And apparently Peter was sobbing with laughter throughout the dwarf wedding was clearly a self-conscious parody of the wedding that had happened two days earlier. And apparently Peter was sobbing with laughter throughout this dwarf wedding. He has a sort of, I don't know whether it's unconscious, whether he's reflective about it, but he has a kind of fascination with mimicking the rituals of Russian kind of elite
斯特列尔齐叛乱之类的事情。我们开篇提到的那场侏儒婚礼发生在她的侄女安娜嫁给库尔兰公爵两天之后。我认为侏儒婚礼显然是对两天前举行那场婚礼的一种自觉的讽刺。而且据说彼得在这场侏儒婚礼的整个过程中都笑得抽泣。他有一种，我不知道他是无意识的，还是对此有所反思，但他对模仿俄罗斯精英阶层生活
life. He's always engaged in this kind of game of parody and play acting. And also subverting his own preeminence as a symbol of Russia with all that kind of stuff of dressing up as a common soldier and marching in his own triumphs. Yeah, exactly. I mean, maybe there's an argument that some of the Roman emperors, like the Julio-Claudians, like Caligula or Nero, they were testing taboos all the time, aren't they? That's part of their so-called depravity, is that they're kicking against the conventions of Roman life.
的仪式有一种迷恋。他总是参与这种模仿和扮演的游戏。同时也颠覆了自己作为俄罗斯象征的崇高地位，做那些诸如把自己打扮成普通士兵并在自己的凯旋仪式上游行之类的事。是的，完全是这样。我的意思是，也许可以说有些罗马皇帝，比如尤里乌斯-克劳狄王朝，像卡利古拉或尼禄，他们一直在试探禁忌，对吧？那是他们所谓堕落的一部分，因为他们在反抗罗马生活的习俗。
But there's something more obviously ludicrous and parodic about what Peter is doing, I think. It's very strange. It enshrines a sense of the grotesque at the absolute heart of his court. Well, here's a really good example. So this vaper was on Hanse. It was in January 1715. Well, here's a really good example. So this Weber was on fantasy. In January 1715, his old tutor, his childhood tutor, who was called Nikita Zotov, he'd made the mock pope of the all drunken synod, as he called it.
但彼得所做的事情中有一种更明显的可笑和讽刺意味，我认为。这真的很奇怪。它将一种怪诞感奉为他宫廷的绝对核心。好吧，这是一个非常好的例子。所以这个韦伯在汉斯。那是在 1715 年 1 月。好吧，这是一个非常好的例子。所以这个韦伯在范塔西。在 1715 年 1 月，他的老导师，他的童年导师，名叫尼基塔·佐托夫，被他册封为那个他所谓的全饮酒主教团的假教皇。
Zotov was 84 and he got married to a 34 year old woman. And to give you a flavor, this is how Weber described the marriage ceremony. The four persons appointed to invite the guests were the greatest stammerers that could be found in all Russia. Old decrepit men who were not able to walk or stand had been picked out to serve for bridesmen, stewards and waiters. There were four running footmen, the most unwieldy fellows, who had been troubled with gout most of their lifetime and were so fat and bulky that they needed others to lead
佐托夫已经 84 岁了，他娶了一个 34 岁的女人。为了让你感受一下，韦伯是这样描述结婚仪式的：受命邀请宾客的四个人是全俄罗斯能找到的最结巴的人。那些无法行走或站立的老弱病残被挑出来担任伴郎、管家和侍者。有四个随从跑腿的，是最笨拙的家伙，他们一辈子大部分时间都受痛风困扰，胖得臃肿，需要别人搀扶
them. The moxar was brought into this ceremony in a float carried by bears. I was wondering if bears would appear. Of course. Because that's been another running theme of the series. The priest, Peter organized the priest, he said I'll sort this out and they found a man who was a hundred years old and had lost his eyesight and his memory. The whole thing just seems like a tremendous lark and a spoof. And yet it is
他们。假沙皇是被一辆由熊拉着的彩车带进这场典礼的。我想知道熊会不会出现。当然会。因为那是这个系列的另一个贯穿始终的主题。牧师，彼得安排了牧师，他说我来搞定这个，他们找到了一个一百岁且失去了视力和记忆的人。整个事情看起来就像一个巨大的恶作剧和滑稽剧。然而它
a real wedding. And it's an example, I think, for us of how hard it is to get into the mindset of Peter's world. I mean, it does feel like a like if you were dropped in there through a time machine, you would find it very hard to work out exactly what's going on. And actually, maybe people themselves find it hard to work out. I think Weber does, doesn't he? Yeah, absolutely. Now, this makes it sound like it's all just sort of madness and bellows and bears and stuff. But obviously there is a seriousness to Peter.
是一场真正的婚礼。在我看来，它是一个例子，说明了理解彼得的世界的心态有多么困难。我的意思是，这确实让人感觉就像如果你通过时间机器被扔到那里，你会发现很难弄清楚到底发生了什么。事实上，也许人们自己也觉得很难弄清楚。我想韦伯是这样的，对吧？是的，绝对是。现在，这听起来好像全都是疯狂、风箱和熊之类的东西。但很显然，彼得也有严肃的一面。
So there's a brilliant book by Lindsay Hughes, which is all about Peter the Great and his times where she talks a lot about Peter's reforms if you're interested in that. Because of the Great Northern War, that turbocharged his efforts to modernize Russia. It's not quite a total war, but it's not far off. So he had to put loads of money into new factories and textiles and iron and copper works and new canals to basically mobilize Russia's natural resources and its manpower for the war. He has a new tax system, a bit like a poll tax called the sole tax. He has a new Senate to replace the council of boyars. He has a system of new government ministries, which are called colleges, which are modeled ironically on the colleges system in Sweden.
所以有一本由林赛·休斯撰写的精彩书籍，全书都关于彼得大帝和他的时代，她在书中大量谈到了彼得的改革，如果你对此感兴趣的话。由于大北方战争，这极大加速了他使俄罗斯现代化的努力。这不完全是一场全面战争，但也差不太多了。因此，他必须投入大量资金到新工厂、纺织品、铁厂和铜厂以及新运河中，以基本上动员俄罗斯的自然资源和人力来应对战争。他有一套新的税制，有点像人头税，叫做人头税。他有一个新的参议院来取代波雅尔委员会。他有一套新的政府部门，被称为学院，讽刺的是，这些学院是以瑞典的学院制度为蓝本建立的。
And the president's always Russian, but he brings in foreign vice presidents to run this to basically run the machinery of government. And above all, I think there's a general ethos that had not really been the case before in Russia. It's not quite a meritocracy, but it's approaching that and it's symbolized by something called the table of ranks. So there are three ladders, one military, one civilian and one for the court with loads of rungs.
而且主席总是俄罗斯人，但他引入了外国副总统来运行这个机构，基本上是运转政府机器。最重要的是，我认为有一种普遍的精神面貌，这在以前的俄罗斯并不真正存在。这不完全是一个精英政治，但它正在接近这一点，并且它由一个叫做官品表的东西所象征。所以有三个梯队，一个军事的，一个文职的，还有一个宫廷的，有很多级别。
And you basically move up this and this is an obsession in all Russian literature, isn't it? Yeah. So Dostoevsky, so crime and punishment, for instance, which is set in St. Petersburg. Yeah. Absolute obsession with getting ranks and the humiliation of not attaining the rank that you're aspiring to. Exactly.
你基本上在这个上面往上爬，这是所有俄罗斯文学中的一个痴迷点，对吧？是的。所以陀思妥耶夫斯基，比如《罪与罚》，背景就设定在圣彼得堡。是的。对获得官阶以及未能达到自己渴望的官阶所带来的羞辱有着绝对的痴迷。完全正确。
So if you read any story by Chekhov or something, people are always like, what rank are you? Can I move up and can I move down? All of this stuff. It's not a complete meritocracy, of course, and it's not a complete temple to enlightenment values. Russia is still very corrupt and very authoritarian. The classic example of this is Peter's great drinking pal, Alexander Menshikov, who was at Poltava, who was the guy who'd introduced him to his wife,
所以如果你读契诃夫或什么人的任何故事，人们总是问：你是什么官阶？我能往上爬吗？我能降职吗？所有这些。当然，这并不是一个完全的精英政治，也不是一个完全的启蒙价值观的圣殿。俄罗斯仍然非常腐败，非常专制。这方面的经典例子就是彼得的伟大酒友亚历山大·缅什科夫，他曾在波尔塔瓦参战，就是那个把他引荐给他的妻子
Catherine. Menshikov is, you know, he would fit right into Putin's Russia. He's incredibly corrupt. He's incredibly corrupt. He's incredibly ambitious. He's sort of accumulating palaces and jewels and bling. He's always getting government contracts and stealing government money. And Peter always forgives him. Peter was furious about all this corruption in the abstract.
叶卡捷琳娜的人。缅什科夫，你知道的，他完全可以融入普京的俄罗斯。他极其腐败。他极其腐败。他极其有野心。他一直在积累宫殿、珠宝和珠光宝气。他总是拿到政府合同并盗窃政府资金。而彼得总是原谅他。彼得在抽象层面上对所有这些腐败愤怒不已。
And at one point he dictated an order one day to his chamberlain Pavel Yagushinsky, who was actually famously not corrupt. And Peter said, right, I want the death penalty for anyone in my government who so much as steals a piece of rope. And Yagushinsky said to him, does your majesty wish to live alone in his empire with no subjects, because we all steal. Some take a little, some take a great deal, but all of us take something. Do you think that Peter's fascination with parody and grotesquerie perhaps is a way of dealing with the tension between the aspiration of his ideals and the evident fact that they can't entirely be realized. So he spends some of his time kind of drawing up plans and playing the Enlightened Death
有一次，他有一天口授了一道命令给他的内侍帕维尔·亚古申斯基，后者实际上以清廉闻名。彼得说，好罢，我要对政府中任何哪怕偷了一根绳子的人判处死刑。而亚古申斯基对他说，陛下希望孤零零地生活在没有臣民的帝国里吗，因为我们都在偷。有的人拿得少，有的人拿得多，但我们所有人都会拿点东西。你认为彼得对讽刺和怪诞的痴迷，也许是处理他的理想抱负与这些抱负显然无法完全实现这一现实之间张力的一种方式吗？所以他把一部分时间用来绘制计划和扮演开明的死亡
Spot and all that kind of thing. And the other time he kind of wallows in drunkenness and dwarf weddings and bears and all that kind of stuff. So it's kind of like the ego in the id to go all Freudian. I think so. You know, Peter is a very serious person. He has great ambitions for Russia. But of course, his ambitions are colliding with reality, I guess. He needs to let off steam, perhaps. He is a very serious person. He has great ambitions for Russia, but of course his ambitions are colliding with reality,
特使之类的角色。而另一部分时间他则沉溺于酗酒、侏儒婚礼、熊和所有诸如此类的事情中。所以这有点像力比多和超我，用弗洛伊德的话来说。我想是的。你知道，彼得是一个非常严肃的人。他对俄罗斯抱有伟大的抱负。但当然，他的抱负与现实发生了冲突，我猜。他需要宣泄一下，也许吧。他是一个非常严肃的人。他对俄罗斯抱有伟大的抱负，但当然他的抱负与现实发生了冲突，
I guess. He needs to let off steam, perhaps. He needs to let off steam. We're not unfamiliar with it now, of course, that there are politicians whose appeal is partly based on making fun of the established rituals. You know, they're sort of having their cake and eating it. And actually two really good examples of that are Boris Johnson and Donald Trump. They're sometimes self mocking.
我猜。他需要宣泄一下，也许吧。他需要宣泄一下。当然，我们现在对此并不陌生，有些政客的吸引力部分基于取笑既定仪式。你知道，他们有点像鱼与熊掌兼得。事实上，两个很好的例子就是鲍里斯·约翰逊和唐纳德·特朗普。他们有时会自我嘲讽。
They sometimes make fun of the conventions and the expectations that other politicians have adhered to. But I suppose the difference is that they are democratic politicians who have to appeal to an electorate to get into power. Peter doesn't need to worry about any of that. No, he can do what he likes, can't he? I mean, that's the thing. And he just thinks, you know, when he went on his grand tour, he didn't want to be constrained by protocol, which is why he went in disguise. And I think there is a kind of restlessness
他们有时会取笑其他政客一直遵循的惯例和期望。但我想区别在于他们是民主政客，必须吸引选民才能获得权力。彼得不需要担心这些。不，他可以随心所欲，对吧？我的意思是，就是这样。他只是觉得，你知道，当他进行宏伟的欧洲之旅时，他不想被礼仪束缚，这就是为什么他微服出巡。我认为他有一种
to him. You can't imagine Peter knowing what we do with him, just knuckling down and obeying the rules and conventions. He has a kind of, is it a way of coping with the terrible traumas of his first 10 years or so? But also for his courtiers. I mean, it must be tricky because you're being encouraged to mock the conventions that uphold life in the palace. But if you go too far, Peter's not going to like that at all.
坐立不安的特质。你无法想象彼得——根据我们对他的了解——会安分守己地服从规则和习俗。他有一种……这是一种应对他前十年左右所经历的可怕创伤的方式吗？但对他的廷臣来说也是如此。我的意思是，这一定很棘手，因为你被鼓励去嘲笑那些维护宫廷生活的习俗。但如果你走得太远，彼得可是一点也不会喜欢这样的。
Yeah. Peter will behead you personally and whip you. Yeah. I mean, it's an absolute tightrope. It is. So an interesting question about Peter is how much he's an enlightened despot. You know, it's a classic kind of a level question. And I think there are lots of ways in which he does anticipate them.
是的。彼得会亲自砍你的头并鞭笞你。是的。我的意思是，这绝对是在走钢丝。确实如此。因此，关于彼得的一个有趣问题是，他在多大程度上是一个开明专制君主。你知道，这是一个经典的高中水平问题。我认为他在很多方面确实预示了他们。
So you could see him as part of a tradition that reaches its kind of most obvious flowering of people like Frederick the great and Joseph the second of Austria, the suspicion of organized religion, the dislike of obscurantism, fascination with science and geography, enthusiasm for kind of top-down modernization and whatnot. If you sort of stretch the definition of enlightened despotism, you can see him as the start of a line that leads all the way to Napoleon, I would say. There is a comparison to be made between Peter and Napoleon, an autocrat, a modernizing autocrat. I mean, Napoleon obviously isn't messing around with dwarves and pies and bears and whatnot
所以你可以把他看作是一个传统的组成部分，这个传统达到了其最明显的巅峰，比如普鲁士的腓特烈大帝和奥地利的约瑟夫二世，对有组织宗教的怀疑，对蒙昧主义的反感，对科学和地理的痴迷，对自上而下的现代化的热情等等。如果你稍微拉伸一下开明专制主义的定义，你可以把他看作是一条一直通往拿破仑的路线的开端，我会这么说。在彼得和拿破仑之间可以做一个比较，一个独裁者，一个推动现代化的独裁者。我的意思是，拿破仑显然没有像那样
in the same way. Well, no, he's not. And so that's why I think Peter is kind of a little bit sui generis. I mean, clearly there is a rationalist element to him. He's a great one for a plan and all of that. But at the same time, he's clearly very interested in the darkness that is the other side of, of reason. Yes.
搞侏儒、馅饼和熊之类的东西。嗯，不，他没有。所以这就是为什么我认为彼得有点独一无二。我的意思是，很明显他身上有一种理性主义的元素。他很热衷于计划之类的事情。但与此同时，明显他非常对理性另一面的黑暗面感兴趣。是的。
There's a lot of darkness to come in this episode when we get to his son. The one thing he does definitely have in common with Napoleon though, is he's a genuine celebrity, a continental celebrity. There's a wonderful description of him. He made a second tour of Western Europe in 1716, 17, when the war was largely won and he went to France this time. He stayed at the Louvre, he visited Louis XV at the Tuileries. Louis XV then was only a little boy, seven years old, and Peter made a great fuss of him, hugging
当我们讲到他的儿子时，这一集中将会有很多黑暗的内容。不过，他与拿破仑确实有一个共同点，那就是他是一个真正的名人，一个全欧洲的名人。对他的描述非常精彩。1716 到 1717 年间，当战争基本赢得胜利时，他进行了第二次西欧之行，这次他去了法国。他住在卢浮宫，他在杜伊勒里宫拜访了路易十五。那时的路易十五还是个七岁的小男孩，彼得对他大加宠爱，拥抱
him and kissing him. And there were wonderful sort of descriptions of him going to meet scientists and going to talk to Catholic theologians. He's drinking a lot. There's a wonderful description by the Duke of Saint-Simon, the great memoirist of 18th century France. You know, he's always asking questions about everything from the tax system to the police, just like he was, you know, almost 20 years earlier when he went to Amsterdam and London. Yeah.
拥抱他、亲吻他。这里面有极好的描述，讲他去见科学家，去和天主教神学家交谈。他喝了很多酒。18世纪法国伟大的回忆录作家圣西门公爵有一段精彩的描述。你知道，他总是对从税收制度到警察的一切事物刨根问底，就像他大约20年前去阿姆斯特丹和伦敦时一样。是的。
We've mentioned a few times Robert K. Mass's book, which is about what? 20,000 pages long or something. Just enormous biography. And he gives some lovely sort of portraits of Peter and his prime. And you can see why people found him such a, an infectious character. He would get up at four o'clock in the morning and he's carries a notebook and he's always writing stuff down.
我们提到过好几次罗伯特·K·玛斯的书，那本书有多少页？大约 2 万页还是什么的？简直是一本庞大的传记。他给出了一些彼得盛年时的可爱肖像。你可以理解为什么人们发现他是一个如此具有感染力的人物。他早上四点钟起床，随身带着笔记本，总是把事情写下来。
He loves playing chess. He loves messing around with his lathe. He likes sailing all of this. He's got some very peculiar quirks. So he has messing around with his lathe, he likes sailing, all of this. He's got some very peculiar quirks. He has an obsession with cockroaches. Whenever he goes to stay in a room, it has to be fully checked and swept for cockroaches. And of course, the thing that a lot of people will know about Peter the Great, because we've referred to it in previous episodes of The Rest is History about other things, is this
他喜欢下棋。他喜欢摆弄他的车床。他喜欢航海，所有这些。他有一些非常奇怪的怪癖。所以他摆弄他的车床，他喜欢航海，所有这些。他有一些非常奇怪的怪癖。他有一种对蟑螂的痴迷。每当他去一个房间住宿时，房间必须经过彻底的检查和清扫以消灭蟑螂。当然，很多人都知道彼得大帝的一点，因为我们在《历史的余烬》之前的节目中提到过其他事情，就是
whole thing about curiosities. You mentioned about the giants. So in 1718, he sent out a demand he said i would like people to send me a quote freaks and monsters that was his words. Lindsey hughes and her book says this produce and i quote a three legged baby a two headed baby a baby with its eyes under its nose and it is below its neck. Siamese twins joined at the chest, a baby with a fish's tail, two dogs born to a 60 year old virgin. I think that's not plausible, frankly. And a baby with two heads, four arms and three legs. And then she says, but the response was not as good as Peter hoped.
关于珍奇物品的这一切。你提到了巨人。所以在 1718 年，他发出要求，说我希望人们给我送来，原话是“奇形怪状的怪物”。林赛·休斯在她的书中说，这产出了——我引用一下——一个三条腿的婴儿、一个双头婴儿、一个眼睛在鼻子下而婴儿在脖子以下的婴儿。胸部相连的连体双胞胎、一条鱼尾巴的婴儿、一个 60 岁处女生下的两只狗。坦率地说，我觉得这不太 plausibe（可信）。还有一个有着两个头、四只手臂和三条腿的婴儿。然后她说，但反响并不像彼得希望的那样好。
What was he after? That sounds a pretty good haul to me. And he would exhibit these in his Kunstkamera, his cabinets of curiosities. Which is still there. Yeah. I think it was St. Petersburg's first museum to open up. It's kind of on the opposite side of the river from the Hermitage and from that massive equestrian statue of Peter on the far side.
他在追求什么？听起来对我来说是个相当不错的收获。他会把这些陈列在他的珍奇柜（Kunstkamera）里。那个柜子现在还在。是的。我想那是圣彼得堡第一座开馆的博物馆。它位于河的对岸，与埃尔米塔日博物馆（冬宫）以及远处的彼得巨型骑马雕像相对。
And it's an incredible place to visit. It goes back to that first visit to Amsterdam where he was fascinated by the ability of Dutch scientists to preserve human flesh within bottles. And those bottles are still there and you can see all these kind of deformed children, babies, whatever, in the bottles. And also there's the skeleton of his giant, Nicolas Bourgeois. Oh, yeah, of course. It's there and it's got his heart his giant Nicola bourgeois. Oh yeah, of course. It's there and it's got his heart and the heart is absolutely huge.
这是一个令人难以置信的旅游胜地。它追溯到他第一次访问阿姆斯特丹，当时他对荷兰科学家将人类肌肉保存在瓶子里的能力着迷。那些瓶子现在还在，你可以在瓶子里看到所有这些畸形的儿童、婴儿等等。还有他的巨人尼古拉斯·布尔茹瓦的骨骼。哦，对，当然。它就在那里，而且它有他的心脏他的巨人尼古拉斯·布尔茹瓦。哦，对，当然。它就在那里，而且它有他的心脏，那颗心脏绝对巨大。
It was one of the most memorable things I remember from visiting St Petersburg. I mean this sort of stuff is quite unsettling I think. Very unsettling. And actually there is a very very unsettling and dark side to Peter's character. Peter is not just hot tempered, he is unbelievably violent. So you go in and you report the taxes from such and such a province are not great this year and he will beat you with a stick or something. He would often at feasts, when the doors are leaping out of pies and there's great japs,
这是我访问圣彼得堡时记忆最深刻的事情之一。我的意思是，这种事情相当令人不安，我认为。非常不安。事实上，彼得的性格中有一个非常、非常令人不安和黑暗的面。彼得不仅脾气暴躁，而且暴力得令人难以置信。所以你进去报告说某某省今年的税收不太好，他就会用棍子之类的东西打你。他经常在宴会上，当侏儒从馅饼里跳出来、大家开着大玩笑时，
he will punch his friends in the face if they say the wrong thing. There's occasions where he would draw his sword and attack them and have to be physically restrained. It's sort of like Alexander the Great and Cletus the Black. Which must make him an alarming father. I would say he's one of the worst fathers you could wish to have actually. And this brings us to the meat of this story, which is such a sad, sad business. So his son, Alexei or Alexis, as he's usually called, was born in February 1690 when Peter was only 18 years old
如果别人说错了话，他会朝朋友的脸上挥拳。有时他会拔剑攻击他们，必须被人强行拉开。这有点像亚历山大大帝和黑克利图斯。这一定让他成了一个令人担忧的父亲。我想说他其实是你所能希望的最糟糕的父亲之一。这就让我们谈到了这个故事的核心，这是一件多么悲伤、悲伤的事情。所以他的儿子，阿列克谢，或者通常被称为阿列克谢，出生于 1690 年 2 月，当时彼得只有 18 岁
and he was married to Eudokia. If you remember Eudokia, he was very conservative. The boring one. Yes. Who he packed off to a nunnery. So he was forced off to a nunnery when Alexis was eight. So Alexis lost his mother when he was eight and he had a succession of German tutors and he studied all the things that you would expect, maths and foreign
他娶了叶多基娅。如果你还记得叶多基娅，她非常保守。那个无聊的人。是的。他把她打发去了修道院。所以在阿列克谢八岁时，她被迫去了修道院。所以阿列克谢在八岁时失去了母亲，他有一连串的德国导师，他学习了你所期望的所有东西，数学和外语
languages, he's taught how to ride and to fence and whatnot. This is so tragic because all the reports of him as a young boy are that he's very bright, studious, eager to please all of this. Do you think that he thinks that he is associated by Peter with his mother? Yes, undoubtedly. Peter despised his wife Eudokia and I think as a young man was just simply not interested in Alexis at all. And Alexis always had the taint, I think, of his mother and indeed grows up and ends
，他被教导如何骑马和击剑之类的事情。这太悲惨了，因为关于他小时候的所有报道都说他非常聪明、好学、渴望取悦所有人。你认为他认为自己被彼得与他的母亲联系在一起了吗？是的，毫无疑问。彼得极其鄙视他的妻子叶多基娅，我认为作为一个年轻男子，他根本对阿列克谢不感兴趣。而且阿列克谢总是带有他母亲的污点，我认为，而且确实长大后并最终
up living up to that that doesn't he. Yeah. So he's very conscious of the fact that his father kind of despises him for being a mummy's boy. I think so. I think so. And I think what's a terrible sign is that Peter seems to have given his pal, Alexander Menshikov, the very blingy hard drinking friend of his special responsibility for Alexis and says,
活成了那样，不是吗？是的。所以他非常清楚这样一个事实：他的父亲因为他是个“妈妈的男孩”而鄙视他。我想是的。我想是的。而且我认为一个可怕的迹象是，彼得似乎把他的死党亚历山大·缅什科夫——那个非常珠光宝气、酗酒的密友——对阿列克谢负有特殊责任，并说，
Oh, why don't you take my son under your wing? And there are stories of Menshikov punching Alexis or dragging him by his hair along the floor in front of Peter. Bloody good laugh. Make a man of him. Making a man of him. When the war breaks out, Peter would sometimes summon him to sort of set peace moments like the storming of Narva.
“哦，你为什么不把我的儿子带在身边照顾呢？”有传言说缅什科夫当着彼得的面殴打阿列克谢，或者拽着他的头发在地上拖拽。真是个好玩的笑话。把他培养成一个真正的男人。把他培养成一个真正的男人。当战争爆发时，彼得有时会召唤他去一些关键的和平时刻，比如攻打纳尔瓦。
But then he would just forget about him for long stretches, like months or years at a time. So that leaves Alexis in Moscow and unlike his father, he loves Moscow. So he loves all the icons, the chanting and the candles and all of that. He does. He's a sort of dreamy teenager and he's very close to his mother's family and they're more conservative and he falls in with lots of priests and stuff. And I think they encourage this because they see him a champion of the old ways and orthodoxy and one day he will
但随后他会把他忘在一边很长时间，比如几个月或几年。这使得阿列克谢留在了莫斯科，和他的父亲不同，他热爱莫斯科。所以他热爱所有的圣像、吟唱、蜡烛以及所有这些。他确实如此。他是一个有点爱做梦的少年，他与他母亲的家族非常亲近，他们更保守，他与许多牧师之类的人混在一起。我认为他们鼓励这一点，因为他们视他为旧道路和正统信仰的捍卫者，有一天他将
succeed and they will be able to turn the clock back on all Peter's reforms. And so that's not boosting his profile with Peter is it? No not at all but also temperamentally they're so different. Peter as we've discussed is so physical, he's so energetic, he's so self-confident and gregarious. And not bookish. His education had been with the lathe. Exactly. And Alexis is very bookish and he's very anxious and melancholy.
继承大统，他们将能够把彼得所有的改革时间倒拨回去。所以这并没有提升他在彼得眼中的形象，对吧？不，一点也没有，而且从性格上讲，他们太不同了。正如我们所讨论的，彼得是如此充满活力，精力充沛，如此自信和合群。而且不爱书本。他的教育是通过车床进行的。正是如此。而阿列克谢非常喜欢书本，并且非常焦虑和忧郁。
He's clearly terrified of his father. So when Peter would summon him, he would often make himself ill by necking medicine, you know, to try to get out of meeting him. Like getting out of PE. Exactly. And there's a brilliant example of this. He went off to study in Dresden and Peter sent him a message and said, I look forward to seeing your geometrical drawings. You can draw me a fort.
他显然非常怕他的父亲。所以每当彼得传唤他时，他经常通过咕咚咕咚喝药来把自己弄病，你知道的，以此来逃避见他。就像逃避体育课一样。完全正确。这有一个绝佳的例子。他去德累斯顿学习，彼得给他传话，说我期待看到你的几何制图。你可以给我画一座堡垒。
Classic Peter. And Alexis was so terrified that he wouldn't be able to do it, that he tried to shoot himself in the hand, but he missed. He was shaking so much. He ended up really badly burning himself with the sort of the pistol. Anyway, in 1710, so when Alexis was turning 20, Peter arranged for him to marry a German princess called Charlotte of Wolfenbüttel.
标准的彼得作风。阿列克谢害怕得觉得自己根本画不出来，于是他试图朝自己的手开枪，结果打偏了。他抖得太厉害了。最后，他用那把手枪把自己烧得非常严重。不管怎样，在1710年，阿列克谢快满20岁时，彼得为他安排了一场婚姻，新娘是沃尔芬比特尔的夏洛特德国公主。
And at first everything seemed fine. Alexis said, well, she's quite nice. Yeah, we get on all right. They got married in Saxony, but they didn't see each other much for the first couple of years. They married in 1711. They sort of see each other off and on. And then by 1713, when they're reunited in St. Petersburg, Alexis has started drinking a lot. And he starts to be very rude to her and to abuse her in front of the servants. And he says, I wish I'd never married you. I actually don't like you at all, but they are still sleeping together
起初一切看起来都很好。阿列克谢说，嗯，她挺不错的。是的，我们相处得挺好。他们在萨克森结了婚，但在最初的几年里，他们并不常见面。他们于1711年结婚。他们算是断断续续地见面。到了1713年，当他们在圣彼得堡团聚时，阿列克谢开始酗酒。他开始对她非常粗鲁，并在仆人们面前虐待她。他说，我真希望从未娶过你。其实我一点也不喜欢你，但他们仍然睡在一起
because in early 1714, she's heavily pregnant with their daughter. And Alexis walks out of the house with the words, goodbye. I'm going to Carlsbad, Sparta. And he goes off to Carlsbad and he doesn't write to her for the next six months. So actually this is kind of behavior like Peter's isn't it? Ironically to his mum. Exactly. And she writes to him, oh I've had a daughter blah blah blah.
因为在1714年初，她怀上了他们的女儿，肚子已经很大了。阿列克谢留下一句“再见，我要去卡尔斯巴德，斯巴达”便走出了家门。然后他去了卡尔斯巴德，在接下来的六个月里没有给她写过一封信。所以实际上这种行为有点像彼得的，不是吗？对他的妈妈来说挺讽刺的。完全正确。而她写信给他，哦，我生了一个女儿，巴拉巴拉巴拉。
And he returns her letters unread. Then in December 1714 he returns to Charlotte but things are worse than ever. He's now drinking loads of brandy a day. He's also got this girl, this Finnish girl who was a prisoner of war from the Great Northern War, who he met at a friend's house. This girl is called Afrosenia. And he moves Afrosenia, she's a teenager, he moves her into a wing of his house and he spends all his time with Afrosenia. Charlotte, who's living in the other bit of the house, he doesn't talk to her at all. She has a terrible leak in her bedroom and water is pouring in and he won't even pay to repair the leak and yet once a week he was still pad along the corridors to charlotte's room as robert came as he puts it coming grimly to make love in hopes of fathering a son to secure his own successions throne.
而他把她的信原封不动地退了回去。接着在1714年12月，他回到了夏洛特身边，但情况比以往任何时候都要糟糕。他现在每天要喝掉大量的白兰地。他还和这个女孩在一起，这个芬兰女孩是大北方战争中的战友，不对，是战俘，他在一个朋友家里遇到了她。这个女孩名叫阿弗罗西尼娅。他把阿弗罗西尼娅——她还是个青少年——接到了他宅邸的一个厢房里，把所有的精力和时间都花在了阿弗罗西尼娅身上。住在宅邸另一部分的夏洛特，他根本不和她说一句话。夏洛特的卧室漏水极其严重，水哗哗地流进来，而他甚至连修缮漏水的钱都不肯出；然而，每周一次，他仍然会拖着沉重的脚步沿着走廊走到夏洛特的房间——正如罗伯特所说，正如他自己所描述的那样——阴沉着脸来行房事，希望能生下一个儿子，来确保他自己的王位继承。
Charlotte is very miserable she She's had a terrible time. She gives birth to a second child in 1715 who's going to end up becoming Peter the second, but nine days later she dies of postpartum fever. That's the end of her tragic story. Now on the day of her funeral, Peter hands Alexis a letter and he says, I mean, imagine you get this letter from your dad. It says, look at me. I'm absolutely brilliant.
夏洛特非常痛苦，她经历了一段可怕的时光。她在1715年生下了第二个孩子，这个孩子最终将成为彼得二世，但九天后她就因产褥热去世了。这就是她悲惨故事的结局。现在，在她葬礼的那天，彼得递给阿列克谢一封信，他说——想象一下你从你爸那里收到这封信。上面写着，看看我。我绝对是个天才。
I've done all these things for Russia. I'm a tremendous man. You, you know, you're an absolute shower of a man. You're a terrible person. And it's not because of your treatment. He doesn't even mention Alexis treatment of his wife, who's dead. You have no inclination to learn war. You don't apply yourself to it.
我为俄罗斯做了这么多事情。我是个了不起的人。而你，你知道的，你简直是个一无是处的废物。你是个糟糕透顶的人。这甚至不是因为你对她的态度。他甚至都没提阿列克谢对已经去世的妻子的态度。你一点学习战争的倾向都没有。你根本不用心。
Again, Peter's obsession with the fate of Constantinople. We don't want to follow the Greeks with whom we are united by the same profession of faith. Idleness and repose weaken them and brought them to that slavery to which they are now so long since reduced. And if you don't mend your ways, says Peter, I will deprive you of the succession as one may cut off a useless member. So that must have helped him with his lack of self-confidence. Yeah, with his mental health. Well, Alexis goes straight to his friends and says, what do you think about this?
又来了，彼得对君士坦丁堡命运的执念。我们不想重蹈希腊人的覆辙，我们与他们有着相同的信仰。懒惰和安逸削弱了他们，让他们陷入了早已沦落至今的那种奴役之中。彼得说，如果你不改过自新，我就会剥夺你的继承权，就像砍掉一个无用的肢体一样。所以这肯定对他的自信心很有帮助。是的，对他的心理健康很有帮助。嗯，阿列克谢直接去找他的朋友们说，你们觉得这事怎么样？
And they unanimously say to him, do you know what? You should just walk away. You are not suited to be the Tsar. Tell your father you just don't want it. So Alexis writes back to Peter and he says, I don't want it. The strength of my mind and of my body is much decayed by sicknesses. I do not think myself fit for government.
他们异口同声地对他说，你知道吗？你干脆一走了之得了。你根本不适合当沙皇。告诉你的父亲你就是不想要。于是阿列克谢给彼得回信说，我不想当。我的精力和体力已经因病大大衰退了。我认为自己不适合治理国家。
Please, exclude me from the succession. Just let me go in peace to be a private citizen. Peter is livid. A month later, he's been brooding for a month and then he writes back to Alexis and he says, you're going to throw away everything I've done for Russia. I cannot resolve to let you live on according to your free will like an amphibious creature, neither fish nor flesh.
求求你，取消我的继承权吧。让我安安静静地做一个平民吧。彼得大发雷霆。一个月后，他生了一个月的闷气，然后回信给阿列克谢说，你要抛弃我为俄罗斯所做的一切。我绝不允许你像两栖动物那样按自己的意愿活着，非鱼非肉。
Change therefore your conduct and either strive to render yourself worthy of them succession or become a monk. And he says, when you get this letter, answer me straight away. If you fail to do it, I shall treat you as a criminal. God, no wonder he was drinking. So Alexis says, I will become a monk actually. Now you mentioned it. And Peter is shocked by this because Alexis has called his bluff. Well, because he gets surprised by a friend, doesn't he? That, you know, you can become a monk, but you can stop being a monk as well. Exactly. At any point, this is win-win. And Peter says, Oh, well, actually becoming a
因此，改变你的行为，要么努力让自己配得上继承权，要么去当个修士。他说，当你收到这封信时，立刻答复我。如果你不这样做，我将把你视作罪犯。天哪，难怪他要借酒浇愁。所以阿列克谢说，既然你这么说，那我干脆去当个修士好了。而彼得对此感到震惊，因为阿列克谢看穿了他的虚张声势。嗯，因为他被一个朋友提醒了，不是吗？就是说，你可以当修士，但你也可以不再当修士啊。完全正确。无论何时，这都是稳赚不赔的买卖。彼得说，哦，好吧，其实当一个
monk is not easy for a young man. Think about it a little more. I will wait six more months. So six more months pass. Peter's Orphan Campaign in the West in Germany. Alexis is in St. Petersburg, holed up miserably with Afrosenia, mistress drinking like a fish drinking like a fish not like a amphibious creature. Do you like a fish. I know the twenty sixth of august seventeen sixteen peter writes to him from coban hagen he says i need your final answer. Monk or crown prince make your mind up and he waits waits and there's no reply and then he hears reports that Alexis has left St. Petersburg and he is coming west to Pomerania and he thinks well fine he's coming to tell me his answer
修士对年轻人来说并不容易。再好好想想吧。我再等六个月。于是又过了六个月。彼得在西方的德国进行孤儿战役。阿列克谢则呆在圣彼得堡，痛苦地和情妇阿弗罗西尼娅躲在一起，借酒浇愁，像条鱼一样喝酒，像条鱼一样喝酒，而不是像两栖动物。你喜欢像鱼一样喝酒。我知道。1716年8月26日，彼得从哥本哈根写信给他，说我需要你最后的答复。修士还是王储，自己做决定吧。他等啊等，却没有任何回音。接着他听到消息说阿列克谢已经离开了圣彼得堡，正向西前往波美拉尼亚。他想，好吧，很好，他是来亲自
in person great I look forward to it and the weeks pass and Alexis there's nowhere to be seen and then comes not for the first time in this series bombshell news Alexis has got as far as Danzig Gdansk but nobody has seen him since and nobody knows where he is Tom he has vanished into thin air. Dominic, this is a stunning development, an incredible twist. And I think it is so shocking that we should take a break and draw our breath. And then we will come back for the final part of this epic series and find out what has happened to Alexis. Did you know that our Sunday Times bestselling book, The Rest is History Returns is now out in paperback. From finding out who British history's biggest lad was to tracing the admittedly hazy
告诉我他的答复的，太好了，我很期待。然而几周过去了，阿列克谢依然不见踪影。紧接着，本系列节目中并非头一次出现的重磅消息传来了：阿列克谢已经到了但泽（格但斯克），但自那以后就没人见过他，也没人知道他在哪里，汤姆。他人间蒸发了。多米尼克，这是一个惊人的发展，一个令人难以置信的转折。我认为这太令人震惊了，我们应该休息一下，喘口气。然后我们将回来参加这个史诗般系列的最后一部分，看看阿列克谢究竟发生了什么。你知道吗，我们《星期日泰晤士报》的畅销书《历史就是这样》（The Rest is History Returns）现在已经出平装版了。从探究英国历史上最大的人生赢家是谁，到追溯《夺宝奇兵》中那些公认扑朔迷离的
ancient origins of Raiders of the Lost Ark, It's filled cover to cover with more curious historical moments than you can crack a lasso at. Plus puzzles and a pub quiz. The rest is history returns available now in all good bookshops. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History and Dominic, you left us on the edge of our seats. The Crown Prince of Russia has vanished. Where's he gone? Right. Tom, the date is the 10th of November, 1716, and we're in Vienna. And we're with a guy called Count Schoenborn, who's the Vice Chancellor of the Habsburg
上古起源，这本书从头到尾都充满了比你能用套马索套住的还要奇妙的历史时刻。此外还有各种谜题和酒吧问答。《历史就是这样：归来》现已在各大优秀书店有售。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史就是这样》，多米尼克，你把我们悬在了悬崖边缘。俄罗斯王储失踪了。他去哪儿了？好吧。汤姆，日期是1716年11月10日，我们在维也纳。我们和一个叫勋伯恩伯爵的人在一起，他是哈布斯堡
Imperial Court. And he's just retired to bed, shortly after a day stuffing himself with schnitzel cake and listening to nice classical music or some such Austrian behavior. And a servant comes in and says, you know, my Lord, there's a, there's a man at the door. He says he's Grand Duke Alexis, son of Peter the Great. And Schoenborn kind of gets back out of bed and he starts putting his clothes back on and suddenly the door swings open and this man bursts in.
帝国宫廷的副首相。他刚刚上床睡觉，此前他刚度过了一天，塞满了炸肉排蛋糕，听着美妙的古典音乐或诸如此类的奥地利做派。一个仆人进来对他说，阁下，门外有个人。他说他是大公阿列克谢，伟大彼得的儿子。勋伯恩便从床上爬起来，开始重新穿衣服，突然门被猛地推开了，这个人闯了进来。
He's hysterical, he's sobbing, he's pacing the room like a madman. He is Alexis. He has fled Russia in terror for his life and arrived in Vienna. So this is great news for the Austrian Emperor. So the Austrian Emperor is called Charles VI and he's now in a very difficult position. Nightmare. What the hell am I going to do now? Do I house him?
他歇斯底里，泣不成声，像个疯子一样在房间里踱步。他就是阿列克谢。他为了保命，在极度恐惧中逃离了俄罗斯，来到了维也纳。所以这对奥地利皇帝来说是个好消息。这位奥地利皇帝名叫查理六世，他现在陷入了一个非常艰难的境地。噩梦。我接下来到底该怎么办？我该收留他吗？
Do I send him back to his father? What do I do? I mean, I can't think of many examples in history where something like this has happened. And he says, well, we'll just keep the whole thing top secret. And he sends Alexis to a remote castle in the northern Tyrol called Arenberg. And so for the next few months, Alexis is housed in this Austrian
我该把他送回他父亲身边吗？我该怎么办？我的意思是，在历史上我简直想不出有多少这样的例子。他说，好吧，我们就把整件事列为最高机密。他把阿列克谢送到北部蒂罗尔一个叫阿伦堡的偏远城堡里。所以在接下来的几个月里，阿列克谢就被安顿在这座奥地利
castle in the strictest secrecy. He's traveled with four Russian servants. He's traveled with loads of books because we said he's very bookish and this girlfriend of his, Afrosenia, this Finnish girl who's disguised as a boy. I mean, it is very like a kind of 18th century melodrama on the stage, isn't it? Right. Mozart would make an opera out of this.
城堡里，受到极其严格的保密。与他同行的有四个俄罗斯仆人。他带了大量的书，因为我们说过他非常书卷气，还有他的这个女朋友，阿弗罗西尼娅，这个伪装成男孩的芬兰女孩。我的意思是，这真的很像舞台上那种18世纪的情节剧，不是吗？没错。莫扎特会以此为题材写一部歌剧的。
They love a girlfriend who's disguised as a page. Exactly. So he's treated very generously. He wants for nothing, but no one is allowed near the castle and the grounds are patrolled by Austrian bodyguards. Now Peter has gone absolutely ballistic that his son has vanished and he has sent Russian agents and diplomats across central Europe to search for him. And one of these men who's been told to look for him is the ambassador to Vienna, he's
他们就喜欢女扮男装的情节。完全正确。所以他受到了非常慷慨的对待。他要什么有什么，但任何人都不准接近城堡，城堡周围由奥地利的贴身警卫巡逻。现在彼得因为儿子失踪而彻底暴怒了，他派出了俄罗斯特工和外交官穿梭于中欧寻找他的下落。奉命寻找他的人之中，有一位是驻维也纳大使，
a man called Veselovsky and he personally tries to retrace Alexis' steps. He goes up to Danzig and he asks questions, have you seen this man? And eventually he finds that a man who was calling himself Korkansky, clearly spoke with a heavy Russian accent, had stayed at various post houses on the road down south towards Austria. And Veselovsky enlists a Russian guard captain called Rumyantsov, who's a huge giant of a man, another giant, to look into this. And Rumyantsov manages to bribe a man in the Imperial Chancery in Vienna who says to him,
他叫维谢洛夫斯基，他亲自试图重走阿列克谢的逃亡之路。他去了但泽并四处打听，你们见过这个人吗？最终他发现一个自称科尔坎斯基的人，说话带有浓重的俄罗斯口音，曾在通往奥地利南下的路上的各个驿站停留过。维谢洛夫斯基招募了一位名叫鲁缅采夫的俄罗斯卫队队长——这是一个身材高大的壮汉，又一个大块头——来调查此事。鲁缅采夫设法贿赂了维也纳帝国 chancery（秘书处）的一个人，那人对他说：
I think you should look in the Tyrol. Rumiantsov goes to the Tyrol and he asks around and he hears rumours of this stranger at Ehrenberg Castle. And he goes as close as he can to the castle and he catches a glimpse of somebody who looks suspiciously like it might be Alexis. The Russian ambassador armed with this news goes to see the Habsburg Emperor Charles and gives him a letter from Peter, a very polite letter not an ultimatum saying could you please send back my son and the Emperor sends a secretary to the castle to break this news to Alexis. Alexis bursts into floods of tears and says I will not go I will not go back to my father and so the Emperor says okay well I will not go. I will not go back to my father. So the emperor says, okay, well, I will move you in secret to the opposite end of my empire, which is Naples.
我觉得你应该去蒂罗尔找找。鲁缅采夫去了蒂罗尔，四处打听，听到了关于埃伦堡城堡里这个陌生人的传闻。他尽可能地靠近城堡，瞥见了一个看起来非常可疑、可能是阿列克谢的人。俄罗斯大使带着这个消息去见哈布斯堡皇帝查理，并交给他一封来自彼得的信。这是一封非常礼貌的信，而不是最后通牒，信中说能否请您把我的儿子送回。皇帝派了一名秘书去城堡向阿列克谢宣布这个消息。阿列克谢放声大哭，说我不会去，我绝不回我父亲那里去，所以皇帝说，好吧，那我就不去了。我绝不回我父亲那里去。所以皇帝说，好吧，那我就把你秘密转移到我帝国的另一端，也就是那不勒斯。
And so in this bonkers scene, Austrian imperial agents load Alexis and Afrosenia and their servants onto a coach and they send them off towards Naples. And Afrosenia is still disguised as a boy, right? Still disguised as a boy right? Still disguised as a boy but is pregnant. But is pregnant by Alexis exactly and what is worse they're meant to be traveling incognito but they're drinking like fish again on the coach generally drawing attention to themselves. Anyway they get to Naples in May 1717 and they are put up in the Castel Sant'Elmo which overlooks the city. By this point, Afrosinia is clearly very heavily pregnant. The months go by and actually they breathe a sigh of relief and they think, great, we've
于是在这个疯狂的场景中，奥地利帝国特工将阿列克谢、阿弗罗西尼娅和他们的仆人塞进一辆马车，把他们送往那不勒斯。阿弗罗西尼娅仍然女扮男装，对吧？依然女扮男装，对吧？依然女扮男装，但她怀孕了。但她确实怀上了阿列克谢的孩子，正是如此。更糟糕的是，他们本该隐姓埋名地旅行，但在马车上却又开始牛饮狂欢，普遍引起了人们的注意。不管怎样，他们在1717年5月到达那不勒斯，被安排住在俯瞰城市的圣埃尔莫城堡里。此时，阿弗罗西尼娅的肚子已经明显很大了。几个月过去了，他们实际上松了一口气，心想，太好了，我们
got away, we've pulled this off. But in fact, they had been spotted on the ride south, of course, because they've drawn attention to themselves. This giant, Rumyantsov and his agents have been tracking them the whole time. And when they're certain that they're in Naples and they've got them, they send a message to Peter and they say, this is where they are. So Peter now sends another representative to Vienna. And this is his very best man.
逃出来了，我们成功了。但事实上，他们在南下的旅途中就已经被人认出来了，因为他们太引人注目了。那个大块头鲁缅采夫和他的特工一路上都在追踪他们。当他们确凿地查明他们在那不勒斯并且掌握了他们的行踪后，便向彼得发了信件，通报了他们的所在地。于是彼得现在又派了另一位代表去维也纳。
This is a guy called Piotr Tolstoy, count Tolstoy from the great novel writing dynasty and Tolstoy is your dictionary definition of a wily old fox. Because he'd been Russia's first ambassador to Constantinople hadn't he? He had and he played it very well. He'd also when the Ottomans went to war he'd been locked up. Yes. There was no kind of Geneva Convention that stopped that happening. And he's also for people who've been listening to the rest of his history for a long time he is the guy who had procured the services of that man Hannibal. Yes, of course. The Cameroonian slave general of Peter the greater than the title of that episode
这个人是他最得力的干将。他是一个叫彼得·托尔斯泰的人，出自那个伟大的小说写作世家的托尔斯泰伯爵，而托尔斯泰简直就是教科书级别的老谋深算的老狐狸。因为他曾担任俄罗斯首任驻君士坦丁堡大使，对吧？他确实当过，而且干得非常出色。当奥斯曼人开战时，他还被关押过。是的。当时可没有什么日内瓦公约来阻止这种事的发生。而且对于长期收听《历史就是这样》的听众来说，他也是那个把那个叫汉尼拔的人弄到手的人。是的，当然。那位来自喀麦隆的黑奴将军，彼得大帝手下的名将，那一期节目的标题就是
was. Of course. Yeah. So it was Tolstoy who had got him. Yes. He found him in the safe markets of Constantinople. Exactly. Well, Tolstoy went straight to the Habsburg Emperor, you know, and he said, look, as a sovereign and as a father, Peter really insists that you should give his son back. And the Emperor says, listen, I can't force him. Alexis is a grown man, but you have my permission to go to Naples and talk to him yourself. So Count Tolstoy goes down to Naples and on the 26th of September, 1717, Alexis is invited to the viceroys palace. And when he gets there there listeners who enjoy this
这个。当然。是的。所以就是托尔斯泰把他弄到手的。是的。他在君士坦丁堡安全的市场上找到了他。完全正确。好吧，托尔斯泰径直去见哈布斯堡皇帝，你知道的，他说，听着，作为一国君主和一位父亲，彼得强烈要求你把他的儿子交出来。皇帝说，听着，我不能强迫他。阿列克谢是个成年人了，但你得到了我的允许，可以去那不勒斯亲自找他谈谈。于是托尔斯泰伯爵前往那不勒斯，在1717年9月26日，阿列克谢被邀请到总督宫。当他到达那里时——对于喜欢这类故事的听众来说——那情景就像《帝国反击战》中兰多·卡尔里森把韩、莱娅等人出卖给达斯·维达的那一刻，因为门开了，阿列克谢惊恐地看到托尔斯泰伯爵就在那里，而托尔斯泰带来了一封他父亲彼得的信。彼得在信中对他说，如果你回来，我会宽恕你，而且会比以往任何时候都更爱你。如果你拒绝，那么我将永远诅咒你，并宣布你为叛徒，找到方法这样对你。意思就是我会派带着诺维乔克或者类似东西的人去干掉你。这就是威胁。阿列克谢显然吓坏了。他请求给她时间来做决定。
kind of thing it is like the moment in The Empire Strikes Back when Lando Calrissian betrays Han and Leia and co to Darth Vader because the door opens and Alexis sees to his horror that Count Tolstoy is there and Tolstoy has brought a letter from his father from Peter and Peter says to him, if you come back, I will pardon and I will love you better than ever. If you refuse, then I curse you forever and I will declare you a traitor and find a way to treat you as such. Meaning I will send men with Novichok or something to bump you off. This is the threat. Alexis is clearly terrified. He asks for time to make up his mind.
然后他下定决心，我做不到。我实在没法面对我父亲。我不想回俄罗斯。此时托尔斯泰开始补刀了。他说，嗯，其实如果你不回去，你父亲已经决定率领一支军队进军意大利把你抓回去。但关键是托尔斯泰贿赂了阿弗罗西尼娅，让她劝说自己的情夫回家。他真是一只老谋深算的老狐狸，不是吗？
And then he decides, I can't do it. I just can't face my father. I don't want to go back to Russia. And Tolstoy now turns the knife. He says, well, actually, if you don't go, your father has decided to march on Italy at the head of an army to bring you back. But crucially Tolstoy bribes Afrosenia to persuade her lover to go back home. He is a wily old fox, isn't he?
他确实是一只老狐狸，而阿弗罗西尼娅我觉得她的道德底线也没多少。我觉得这么说挺公平的。于是阿列克谢崩溃大哭，他说，好吧，我回去，但有两个条件。第一，我能在乡下安安静静地生活；第二，我能和阿弗罗西尼娅生活在一起，因为我太爱她了，她对我太重要了。彼得说，行吧，随便你，只要你肯回来就行。于是他们出发了。从那不勒斯向北，他们到达了威尼斯，在那里托尔斯泰说服他把阿弗罗西尼娅留了下来。
He is a wily old fox and Afrosenia I don't think is overburdened with moral scruples. I think it's fair to say. So Alexis breaks down in tears and he says, all right, I'll go back on two conditions. One that I can live quietly in the country and two that I can live with Afrosenia because I love her so much and she's so important to me. And Peter says, yeah, fine, whatever, as long as you come. So off they go. North from Naples, they get to Venice and there Tolstoy persuades him to leave Afrosenia behind.
他说她大腹便便的。她可不想翻越阿尔卑斯山。于是他们把她留下了。到1718年1月，他们到达了里加，当然，此时那里已经被俄罗斯军队占领。阿列克谢随即被塞进一辆马车，送往莫斯科附近的特维尔，等待他父亲的到来。当阿列克谢的老朋友们听说他要回俄罗斯时，他们吓坏了。他的一位朋友瓦西里·多尔戈鲁基亲王说，阿列克谢真是个大笨蛋，迎接他的将是一口棺材而不是一场婚礼。
He says she's heavily pregnant. She doesn't want to be crossing the Alps. So they leave her behind. By January, 1718, they've reached Riga, of course now occupied by Russian troops. And Alexis is immediately kind of loaded into a carriage and sent to Tver, which is near Moscow, to await his father. And when Alexis' old friends hear that he's coming back to Russia, they are horrified. One of his friends, Prince Vasily Dolgoruky, said, what a mug Alexis is, he will have a coffin rather than a wedding.
于是1718年2月3日，俄罗斯的权贵们聚集在克里姆林宫宏伟的大朝见厅里。神职人员、贵族、公职人员，四周全都是近卫军营。彼得走了进来，在王座上坐下，接着阿列克谢在托尔斯泰伯爵的押送下走了进来，双膝跪地，恳求父亲宽恕。彼得痛斥了他，然后说，我可以宽恕你，但有一个条件——彼得之前其实一直没提这个。他说你必须如实交代你逃跑的真相以及你所有同谋的名字。所以彼得断定阿列克谢不仅仅是独自行动，而是参与了一个更广泛的阴谋，也许是为了推翻彼得、破坏他的政权，诸如此类。
So 3rd February 1718, all the bigwigs of Russia assembled in the great audience hall of the Kremlin. Clergy, noblemen, public officials, the place is surrounded by battalions of guardsmen. Peter comes in and he takes his place on the throne and then Alexis is escorted in by Count Tolstoy and he falls to his knees and begs his father for pardon. Peter denounces him and then he says, I will pardon you, but there is one condition which Peter hasn't actually mentioned till now. He says you must reveal the truth of your flight and the names of all your fellow conspirators. And so Peter is assuming that Alexis hasn't just been operating on his own, but is part of a much broader plot to perhaps overthrow Peter to destabilize his throne, whatever.
完全正确。所以我觉得我们这就来到了这个故事的核心，这有点像是把我们做的第一集节目联系起来了——那一集是关于彼得与索菲亚以及斯特列利奇近卫军之间的宿怨，以及那种偏执等等。最终以一波暴力的刑讯逼供告终，不是吗？当斯特列利奇近卫军发动最后一次叛乱时，他确信那里存在着一个实际上并不存在的阴谋。完全正确。
Exactly. So here I think we come to the nub of this story, which is a kind of a link between the very first episode we did, which is about the feud between Peter and Sophia and the Streltsy and that kind of paranoia and stuff. And which ended up in a violent kind of wave of torture, didn't he? When the Streltsy do their final rebellion and he's convinced that there's a conspiracy there that wasn't actually there. Exactly.
而现在我觉得，这既是对那段历史的回顾，同时这也预示了——坦率地说——20世纪俄罗斯历史上的许多主题：作秀审判、怀疑、偏执、对内部敌人的执着搜寻。因为彼得显然（考虑到他的童年，我猜这是可以理解的）对针对他的阴谋这一概念有着病态的执念。如果没有这样一个阴谋，他甚至会觉得有必要捏造一个，因为必须得有这么个阴谋。所以在这次盛大集会几天后，他对阿列克谢说，我需要你把所有跟你谈过我们关系的人的名字都列出来。
And now I think this, it looks back to that, but also so many of the themes of this anticipate frankly 20th century Russian history, show trials, suspicion, paranoia, an obsessive search for enemies within. Because Peter is clearly, I guess for understandable reasons, given his boyhood, he is obsessed with the idea of a conspiracy against him. And if there isn't one, he almost feels the need to invent it because there must be one. So a few days after this great sort of assembly, he says to Alexis, I need you to list for me everybody you've ever spoken to about our relationship.
而阿列克谢完全听信了这话，开出了一份长长的名单，上面列满了亲戚、朝臣、朋友和家庭教师。彼得一拿到这份名单，立刻给圣彼得堡的亚历山大·缅什科夫下达命令：关上城门，封锁全城，然后派你的特工去把名单上的每一个人都给我抓起来。也就是说，包括贵族、主教、军官，还有阿列克谢所有的前仆人。我们要对他们所有人进行审讯，把这个阴谋查个水落石出。名单上的其中一个人是阿列克谢的母亲、彼得的前妻叶夫多基娅。所以她还在世。
And Alexis, who is completely gullible, produces this huge list of relatives and courtiers and friends and tutors and as soon as Peter has the list in his hands, he sends orders to Alexander Menshikov in St Petersburg, close the gates and seal off the city and now send your agents out to round up every single person on this list. So that's aristocrats, it's bishops, it's officers, all Alexis's former servants. We're going to interrogate them all and get to the bottom of this conspiracy. Now one of the people on this list is Alexis's mother, Peter's ex-wife Eudokia. So she's still around.
她过去19年一直待在苏兹达尔的修道院里。但她一直在给阿列克谢写信，更糟糕的是彼得早把她给忘了。但当他的特工赶到时，他们发现她已经不再当修女了。哦，所以她的头发又长出来了。她的头发长回来了，不仅如此，她还开始谈恋爱了，对象是她卫队的队长——本该负责看守她的人，一个名叫斯捷潘·格列博夫的男子。于是彼得说，什么？他下令逮捕了格列博夫，还有修道院院长和一些修女。
She's been in the monastery in Suzdal for the last 19 years But she has been writing to Alexis and there is worse Peter just forgotten about her. But when his agents arrived they find she's given up being a nun Oh, so she's growing her hair back. Her hair has returned and what is more? She has been living in a relationship With the captain of her guards the man who's meant to to be guarding her is a man called Stepan Glebov. And so Peter says, what? And he has Glebov arrested as well as the head of the convent and some of the nuns.
多米尼克，我可不想成为格列博夫。你绝对不会想的，原因接下来就会变得显而易见。于是他们开始进行作秀审判。这些审判在克里姆林宫的大厅里举行。彼得亲自担任首席检察官，他对名单上的所有人提出了指控。以修道院里的叶夫多基娅为例，那些什么都没做的修女们被判处公开鞭笞。叶夫多基娅被送到北方一个真正偏远的修道院，但其他一些囚犯则被判处死刑、用九尾鞭毒打或流放。
Dominic, I would not want to be in Glebov's boots. You absolutely would not for reasons that will now become apparent. So now they begin the show trials. These are held in the great hall of the Kremlin. Peter himself acts as chief prosecutor and he makes the case against all of the names on this list. To give the example of Eudokia in the convent, the nuns who have done nothing are sentenced to be publicly flogged. Eudokia is sent to a really remote convent up in the north, but some of the other prisoners are sentenced to death or beaten with a knout or exiled.
因为哪个法官能经受得住检察官的上诉诱惑，如果这个检察官就是沙皇本人呢？完全正确。所以许多判刑都是在红场执行的。我的意思是，这真是彼得大帝标志性的残暴作风：用铁锤把人的骨头砸碎，割掉鼻子，拔掉舌头。但最糟糕的命运留给了这个家伙——看守叶夫多基娅的卫队队长斯捷潘·格列博夫。记住，他其实什么坏事都没做。好吧，他跟彼得的前妻睡了，但那是他的前妻。我可不会去跟彼得大帝的前妻睡觉。对，这倒也是。好吧，我的意思是，你可不想落得这般下场。于是，格列博夫被九尾鞭狠狠抽打，并用烧红的铁块烙烫。他被绑在一块钉满尖刺的木板上，就这样被晾在那里三天，他们不断地对他说，招供吧。而他说，招供什么？我又从来没有参与过什么阴谋。最后，他们把格列博夫抬起来，把他穿在一根木桩上。有些记载说这木桩插得极其巧妙，竟然避开了他身上所有的要害器官，然后他就被留在这根木桩上慢慢下沉——我不知道如果一个人被穿在木桩上会发生什么——他花了14个小时才死去。天哪。我的意思是，可能确实有更残酷的死法，但我实在想不出几个了。
Because what judge can resist the appeal of the prosecutor if the prosecutor is the Tsar? Exactly. So a lot of the sentences were carried out in Red Square. I mean, it's the classic, you know, Peter the Great carry on of people being broken with hammers on the wheel, people having their noses sliced off, having their tongues ripped out. But the worst fate of all is reserved for this bloke, Stepan Glebov, the captain of the guards, guarding Eudokia. And remember, he has done nothing wrong. Well, he has slept with Peter's ex-wife, but she's his ex-wife. I wouldn't sleep with Peter the Great's ex-wife. No, fair enough. Well, I mean, you don't want to end up like this. So, Glebov is lashed with the knout and he's burned
没有。尽管他没有找到任何阴谋的证据，但彼得从来没有想过其实根本没有什么阴谋，而且他手下的走狗没有一个敢跟他争辩这件事。否则他们就会招致怀疑。完全正确。这让人非常强烈地联想到20世纪30年代的斯大林，因为你该如何证明自己清白，去对抗一个根本不存在的阴谋呢？至于阿列克谢，他在这个时候大概能期盼的最好结果就是被流放到
with red hot irons. He's stretched out on a plank with spikes driven into his flesh and left there for three days and they keep saying to him, confess. And he says, confess what? Like, I was never part of any conspiracy. And finally, they take Lebov and they impale him on a wooden stake which some accounts say was so artfully inserted that it missed all his vital organs and then he's left on this stake to sort of slowly descend I suppose, I don't know what happens to you if you're impaled on a stake, and it took him 14 hours to die. Oh God. I mean there may well be grimmer ways to die, but I can't think of many.
修道院去。但当然，如果彼得坚信他真的是某个阴谋的核心，那么潜台词就是这个阴谋还会继续，即使他在修道院里，他也将成为阴谋和反对势力的焦点。因此目前彼得将他软禁在圣彼得堡，而可怜的阿列克谢——这个如此悲剧性的人物，又是如此地自己坑自己——一直在苦苦哀求。求求你们。我能见见阿弗罗西尼娅吗？你答应过我可以和她一起生活的，我太爱她了。
No. And even though he's found no evidence of the conspiracy, Peter, it never occurs to him that there isn't one and none of his henchmen ever argue with him about it. Then they would come under suspicion. Exactly. It feels very much reminiscent of Stalin in the 1930s because how can you prove your innocence of a conspiracy that never actually existed? Now as for Alexis, the best that he can probably hope for at this point is to be exiled to
最后她被带到首都接受审讯，一切对阿列克谢来说都急转直下。她支持他吗？她没有，汤姆。她没有。她没有支持自己的男人。因此，在她的行李中，彼得的特工发现了阿列克谢写给俄罗斯各路权贵的信件草稿，信中抱怨了他所受到的虐待。彼得亲自审问了阿弗罗西尼娅，他把她带来见自己，坐下来盘问她，这对她来说一定吓坏了。她当场就招了。她说，我从来不想去。是阿列克谢强迫我的。我跟他睡完全是在胁迫之下。
a monastery. But of course, if Peter believes he was really the center of a conspiracy, then the implication is that the conspiracy would continue, that even if he's in a monastery, he will be the focus for plots and opposition. So for the time being, Peter keeps him under house arrest in St. Petersburg and all the time Alexis poor Alexis who's such a tragic figure and is so is so much his own worst advocate. He's begging and begging. Please. Can I see Afrosenia? You promised me that I could live with her I love her so much and
他总是向你抱怨个不停，总是发牢骚。他一直在向哈布斯堡皇帝批评你。每当他听到俄罗斯军队发生哗变或哗变传言时，阿列克谢都欣喜若狂。他经常谈论他当上沙皇之后要做什么。他说他会废除你所有的改革，他会抛弃圣彼得堡，他会把权力还给教会，他讨厌奴隶。他讨厌船只。他会放弃你所有的对外征服。彼得说，好吧，这就是证据。这不就来了。他命人把阿列克谢带进来。
finally she is brought to the capital and questioned and it all goes horribly wrong for Alexis. Does she stand by him? She does not, Tom. She does not. She does not stand by her man. So in her luggage, Peter's agents find drafts of letters that Alexis had
阿弗罗西尼娅怎么样了？她根本没有受到惩罚，一点惩罚都没有。当阿列克谢被带进来时，他崩溃了。他精神彻底崩溃了。他对父亲说，是的，我确实就你写信给哈布斯堡皇帝。我确实说过你的坏话，但我当时喝醉了。是的，我确实谈过当我统治俄罗斯时我会做什么，但我从未密谋反对你，也没想过要杀死你。然后
written to various kind of big wigs in Russia complaining about his treatment. And Peter has Afrosenia, he questions her personally, he has her brought to see him and he sits down and questions her, must have been terrifying for her. She cracked straight away. She said, I never wanted to go. Alexis forced me. I only slept with him under duress.
彼得说，那么，你听到叛乱和起义的传闻时幸灾乐祸这事怎么说？此时阿列克谢给出了一个精神错乱般自取灭亡的回答。他说，听到叛乱的传言我很兴奋，但我相信只有当你死了之后他们才会来找我，因为他们计划杀掉你。我并不相信他们会废黜你并让你活下去。但如果在你活着的时候他们找我，只要他们实力足够强大，我可能就会跟他们走。是的，这太疯了。
He was always whining about you, always complaining. He was always criticizing you to the Habsburg emperor. Whenever he heard of a mutiny or rumors of mutinies in the Russian army, Alexis was delighted. He often talked about what he would do when he became Tsar. He said he'd scrap all your reforms, he would abandon St Petersburg, he'd give power back to the church, He hates slaves. He hates ships. He'd give away all your foreign conquests. And Peter says, well, this is the proof. Here we go. He has Alexis brought in.
这是一个语无伦次但又极度自证其罪的回答。于是阿列克谢被捕了，并被关押在彼得保罗要塞——正如你所说，汤姆，那是圣彼得堡的基石。他的作秀审判于6月14日开始。彼得再次亲自担任检察官。他说，阿列克谢作为阴谋的一部分逃往奥地利。
What happens to Afrosenia? She's not punished at all, not punished at all. And when Alexis is brought in, he collapses. He has some kind of nervous breakdown. He says to his father, yes, I did write to the Habsburg emperor about you. I did speak ill of yousburg Emperor about you. I did speak ill of you, but only when I was drunk. Yes, I did talk about what I would do when I rule Russia, but I never plotted against you or meant to kill you. And then
他一直在与哈布斯堡皇帝密谋。他企图借助俄罗斯的哗变者、叛军以及外国军事援助来夺取王位。而且他对此一直在撒谎。当彼得陈述完案情后，阿列克谢并没有否认。他招认了。他招认了一个我不相信、而且我想没有任何历史学家会相信它曾经存在的阴谋。
Peter says, well, what about this business about you rejoicing when you heard reports of mutinies and rebellions? And now Alexis gives a dementedly self-destructive answer. He says, I was excited at the talk of mutinies, but I believe they would only call for me when you were dead because they planned to kill you. I didn't believe they would dethrone you and let you live. But if they'd call me in your lifetime, probably I would have gone if they had been strong enough. Yeah, that is mad.
那他为什么要这么做？为什么人们在20世纪30年代会这么做？他们被打垮了，他们希望这是获得宽大处理的唯一途径，因为很显然法庭不会接受他无罪的辩解。所以最好的办法或许就是假装自己有罪并乞求宽恕。但彼得并没有原谅他。应彼得的要求，法庭下令进行进一步审讯。这意味着彼得的故事中在很多方面最黑暗的一章，我认为。
It's a rambling but incredibly self-incriminating answer. So Alexis is arrested and he's imprisoned in the Peter and Paul fortress, which as you said, Tom, is the sort of foundation stone of St. Petersburg. And his show trial begins in June, 14th of June. And again, Peter acts as the prosecutor himself. He says, Alexis, he fled to Austria as part of a plot.
所以在6月19日，阿列克谢挨了25下九尾鞭。这通常足以致人死命。你知道的，你被这种巨型皮鞭抽打，背上的皮肉都被撕裂。五天后，他又挨了15下，他的背此时已经彻底毁了。只剩下一团血肉模糊的东西。现在他什么都招了。他告诉托尔斯泰伯爵，是的，我希望我父亲死。我本会花钱让奥地利人对他进行军事干预。于是在那个晚上，凭借这些口供，法庭判处他死刑。他们说他犯下了可怕的弑父大罪——首先是对国家之父的背叛，其次是对生身父亲的背叛——彼得所有的亲信和走狗都在这份判决书上签了名。
He was plotting with the Habsburg emperor. He was intending to seize the throne with Russian mutineers and rebels and with foreign military aid. And he's been lying about it ever since. And when Peter has made the case, Alexis doesn't deny it. He confesses. He confesses to a conspiracy that I don't believe and I don't think any historian believes existed.
所以问题是，彼得会下令对自己的亲生儿子执行死刑吗？这个儿子其实内心深处什么坏事都没做。所有人都在等待结果揭晓。接着在6月26日星期二，圣彼得堡流言四起，传闻阿列克谢突发中风暴毙了。官方发布的说法是他是中风身亡的。彼得赶到他在监狱的病床前。阿列克谢做了彻底的忏悔。他痛改前非。父子二人相拥。
So why is he doing that? Why did people do it in the 1930s? They're broken and they hope this is the only way to get clemency because it's very clear that the court will not accept his claim that he's not guilty. So maybe the best thing to do is to pretend that he is guilty and beg for forgiveness. But Peter doesn't forgive him. At Peter's request, the court orders further interrogation. And what this means is the darkest chapter of all in many ways in Peter's story, I think.
阿列克谢做了临终祈祷，事情就这样结束了。但实际上，这并不是事情的真相。我们从要塞的日志中了解到了真实发生的事情。实际上，那天清晨，彼得和他的亲信——包括托尔斯泰伯爵和亚历山大·缅什科夫——聚集在刑讯室里，把阿列克谢带到他们面前，对他折磨了三个小时。几个小时后，阿列克谢死了，
So on the 19th of June, Alexis was given 25 lashes of the knout. That will often be enough to kill you. You know, you're beaten with this giant leather whip, chunks of flesh off your back. Five days later, he's given another 15 lashes and his back has now been completely destroyed. It's just a sort of mass of bleeding flesh. And now he's confessing to anything. He tells Count Tolstoy, yes, I wanted my father dead. I would have paid the Austrians to intervene militarily against him. And so that evening armed with that that the court sentences him to death. He's guilty they say of a horrid double patricide first against the father of his country and next against his father by nature and all of Peter's cronies and henchmen sign their names on this sentence.
实际上是被他亲生父亲活活拷打致死的。所以这简直是一个令人难以置信的恐怖故事。罗伯特·K·马西在他的传记《彼得大帝》中，将之与伊凡雷帝杀死自己的亲子进行了对比——这是俄罗斯历史上非常著名的一个场景。那是伊利亚·列宾创作的一幅非常著名的画作。不同之处在于，伊凡雷帝杀死自己的儿子是在暴怒之下动手，事后充满了杀害儿子的悔恨。但这里的严刑拷打是有预谋的。
So the question is will Peter order the sentence against his own son who really deep down has done nothing wrong to be carried out. And everyone's waiting to find out the answer. And then on Tuesday the 26th of June, the rumours sweeps in Petersburg that Alexis has dropped dead of a stroke of some kind. And the story is given out that he had this stroke. Peter rushed to his bedside in the prison. Alexis made a full confession. He repented. Father and son embraced.
我的意思是，如果你想想那些酷刑、审讯、公开羞辱，这些已经持续了好几个星期，可以说也是长达多年的一种清算的一部分。但现在他们又折磨起他来，这个可怜的人背上的皮肉都被鞭笞得支离破碎，而他们还在对他施加天知道什么样的进一步酷刑。是的，很难想象会有父亲对自己的亲生骨肉做出这种事，但彼得的行为往往极其刷新人的想象力，我猜。是的。阿列克谢被举行了国葬，据报道彼得在葬礼上哭了。
Alexis was given the last rites and that was the end of that. But actually, this isn't what happened. We know what happened from the logbook with the fortress. Actually, earlier that morning, Peter and his closest cronies, including Count Torstoy and including Alexander Menshikov, gathered in the torture chamber and had Alexis brought to them, and they worked on him for three hours. And a few hours later, Alexis died,
但我们也知道，那周他还去参加了大量的宴会和舞会，来庆祝波尔塔瓦战役的周年纪念，事后他还铸造了一枚奖章，仿佛是在庆祝一场伟大的胜利，奖章上刻着太阳冲破云层的图案，铭文写着：“天际已经放晴。”我的意思是，想象一下在自己亲生孩子死后做出这种事。我猜问题在于阿列克谢是名正言顺的继承人。那么现在王位继承怎么办？他有几个女儿，十几岁的女儿安娜和伊丽莎白，他还有阿列克谢的儿子彼得，只有三岁，但
effectively having been tortured to death by his own father. So it's just an unbelievably horrifying story. And in his biography, Peter the Great, Robert K. Massey compares it with Ivan the Terrible killing his own son, which is a very famous scene in Russian history. It's a very famous painting by Ilya Repin. And the difference is that Ivan the Terrible killed his own son by lashing out against him in a fit of rage and then was full of remorse that he had killed his son. But the torture is kind of premeditated.
实际上她们都不太合适，所以他让他的妻子叶卡捷琳娜——也就是前玛尔塔·斯卡夫龙斯卡娅，那个快乐的女人——加冕为女皇，他为她举行了一场盛大的加冕典礼，这是在1724年，这显然是一个标志，表明她将成为他的继承人，这太不可思议了。我的意思是，她是一个目不识丁的立陶宛农家女，曾作为战俘来到俄罗斯，但这标志着彼得的绝对统治力和他的专制威权。是的。你知道的，这在1728年代他成长的时候是不可想象的。这也是他一生中在多大程度上改造了俄罗斯的一个衡量标准吧。
I mean if you think about the torture, the interrogations, the public humiliation, that had gone on for weeks and arguably was part of a passing that had gone on for years. But now they're turning up, the poor man has his back lashed to pieces and they're inflicting God knows what further tortures on him. Yeah, hard to imagine I think any father doing that to their own child, but Peter often behaves in ways that rather stretch the imagination, I guess. Yeah. Alexis was given a state funeral and the reports that Peter wept at it.
他这时候多大了？他现在52岁。他不是个老人，他比你年轻，汤姆。我觉得可以公平地说，他可不像你那样精瘦健美。他是一个非常阴郁、沮丧的人物。层出不穷的贪腐丑闻真的让他焦头烂额。其中有一个非常著名的丑闻是，叶卡捷琳娜的内侍、名叫威廉·蒙斯的人——他曾是彼得旧情人安娜的兄弟——卷入了一桩巨大的行贿受贿丑闻。彼得下令将他斩首。
But we know that he also that week went to loads of banquets and balls to celebrate the anniversary of the battle of Poltava and afterwards he had a medal struck as if he was celebrating a victory with the image of the sun breaking through clouds and the inscription read, the horizon has cleared. I mean imagine doing that about the death of your own child. I guess the issue is that Alexis was the obvious heir. So what now about the succession? He's got a couple of daughters, teenage daughters, Anna and Elizabeth, and he's got Alexis's son Peter, who's only three, but
但我们知道，那周他也去了无数的宴会和舞会，来庆祝波尔塔瓦战役周年纪念，事后他还让人铸造了一枚奖章，就好像他在庆祝一场胜利一样，上面刻着太阳冲破云层的图案，铭文写着：“地平线已经晴朗”。我的意思是，想象一下，在自己亲生孩子的死上这样做。我想问题在于，阿列克谢是理所当然的继承人。那么现在关于继承权怎么办？他有几个女儿，十几岁的女儿安娜和伊丽莎白，他还有阿列克谢的儿子彼得，才三岁，但是
actually none of them are quite right and so he has Catherine, his wife, the former Marta Skavronska, the jolly one, yes, he has her crowned as empress, he has a big coronation for her, this is in 1724, this is clearly a marker that she is going to be his successor, which is an amazing thing. I mean, she's an illiterate Lithuanian peasant girl who had come to Russia as a prisoner, but it's a sign of Peter's dominance, his autocratic sway. Yeah. You know, something unthinkable in the 1680s when he was growing up. A measure of just how much he's transformed Russia, I guess, over the course of his life.
其实他们当中没有一个完全合适，所以他让他的妻子叶卡捷琳娜——也就是曾经的玛尔塔·斯卡夫龙斯卡娅，那个快乐的女人，是的——加冕为女皇，为她举行了盛大的加冕典礼，这是在1724年，这显然是一个标志，表明她将成为他的继承人，这真是一件了不起的事。我的意思是，她是一个目不识丁的立陶宛农家女孩，曾作为俘虏来到俄罗斯，但这标志着彼得的绝对统治，他的专制威权。是的。你知道，这在20世纪80年代（注：原文如此）他成长的时候是不可想象的。我想，这也衡量了他一生中对俄罗斯改造了多少。
How old is he by this point? So he's now 52. He's not an old man, he's younger than you Tom. I think it's fair to say he's not a lean fit honed figure as you are. He's a very moody depressed figure. There's endless corruption scandals which are really getting him down. So there's a very famous one when Catherine Chamber Chamberlain, who's called William Mons, who is the brother of Peter's old mistress, Anna, he's been in a huge bribery scandal. Peter has him beheaded
到这个时候他多大了？所以他现在52岁了。他不是个老头，他比你年轻，汤姆。我想公平地说，他可不像你那样身材精瘦、健美。他是一个非常阴郁、沮丧的人。无休止的腐败丑闻让他心情非常低落。有一个非常著名的丑闻，叶卡捷琳娜的内侍（注：原文Chamberlain可指宫廷内侍）名叫威廉·蒙斯，他是彼得的老情妇安娜的兄弟，他卷入了一桩巨大的行贿丑闻。彼得下令将他斩首。
and he gives Catherine Mons' head in a jar. Preserved, like all the babies in the museum. Yeah, preserved. Odd thing to do to your wife, but there you go. Peter at this stage is really not a well man. So he's been boozing constantly for decades and that has taken its toll. And he has also, we promised sort of spa related action. He's been drinking colossal amounts of ferrous mineral water. So he would drink 21 glasses of ferrous mineral water every morning.
他把凯瑟琳·蒙斯的头放在了一个罐子里。像博物馆里所有的婴儿一样，被保存了下来。是的，被保存了。对自己的妻子做这种事挺奇怪的，但事情就是这样。彼得在这个阶段确实是个很不健康的人。他几十年一直在酗酒，这损害了他的身体。而且他——我们之前承诺过会有温泉相关的行动——一直在喝大量的铁质矿泉水。所以他每天早晨要喝21杯铁质矿泉水。
And would he do this for his health? Yeah, but I don't think it does do you any good. I think even the most enthusiastic habitue of a German spa would say, come on, that's a bit much. And does it have any malign consequences? Well, now we're going to get into the thorny issue of Peter's bladder. Peter has a long running urinary infection, which probably left him in agony for two years and by the late summer of 1724, he's in unbelievable agony.
他这么做是为了健康吗？是的，但我不认为这能对你有什么好处。我想，即使是德国温泉最狂热的爱好者也会说，得了吧，这有点过头了。这有什么恶劣后果吗？好了，现在我们要讨论彼得膀胱这个棘手的问题了。彼得长期患有泌尿系统感染，这可能让他痛苦了两年之久，到1724年夏末，他正经历着难以置信的痛苦。
He can't go to the toilet at all. And they finally get a surgeon from England who inserts a catheter up him and manages to extract a huge amount of blood and pus from Peter's bladder. I mean, you would not want to be the doctor that has to do that to Peter, would you? But nor would you want to be at the other end of the doctor's catheter, I think. No, you wouldn't. So eventually he passes this huge stone and things seem to improve, but then in January 1725 he collapses. The doctors investigate. There's more catheter action and they find out something has gone terribly wrong with his bladder and they manage to remove
他完全无法上厕所。他们最终从英国请来了一位外科医生，为他插入导尿管，并设法从彼得的膀胱中抽出了大量的血液和脓液。我的意思是，你绝对不想成为那个必须对彼得做这件事的医生，对吧？但你也不想成为医生导尿管的另一端，我想。不，你不会的。于是他最终排出了这块巨大的结石，情况似乎有所改善，但到了1725年1月，他虚脱了。医生们进行检查。又进行了一次导尿操作，他们发现他的膀胱出了大问题，他们设法取出了
two liters of putrid urine. Oh god I think that's the the first appearance of putrid urine on the rest is history. In more than 700 episodes. It's an exciting moment in the history of this podcast. Well Peter seems to recover a little bit but then he goes into massive convulsions and on the afternoon of the 27th of January 1725 he asks for convulsions and on the afternoon of the 27th of January, 1725, he asks for a writing tablet and on the writing tablet, he writes the words, leave everything to... Then he falls down.
两升恶臭的尿液。哦天哪，我想这是“余下皆历史”节目中第一次出现恶臭的尿液。在700多期节目中。这是本播客历史上激动人心的时刻。好吧，彼得似乎恢复了一点，但随后他陷入了剧烈的抽搐，在1725年1月27日下午，他要求——在1725年1月27日下午，他要求拿一块写字板，在写字板上，他写下了这样几个字：把一切留给……然后他倒了下去。
Hollywood timing. He passes out, drops the pen and never wakes up again. And he died at six o'clock the next morning with Catherine at his bedside. And a last nice detail for you. When he was dead, the doctors cut him open and they found his bladder had been infected with gangrene. And I quote from Robert K. Massey, his sphincter muscle was so swollen and so hard that only with difficulty could it be cut by a knife.
好莱坞式的时机。他晕了过去，笔掉了下来，再也没有醒来。第二天早上六点，他在凯瑟琳的陪伴下去世了。还有一个给你们的精彩细节。他死后，医生们剖开了他的身体，发现他的膀胱已经感染了坏疽。我引用罗伯特·K·马西的话：“他的括约肌肿胀得如此厉害，如此坚硬，以至于刀子都很难将其切开。”
Oh God. So just as he wanted Catherine succeeded him, but Menchikov was the real ruler of Russia. So he's the bling oligarch guy. The bling oligarch. That continued for another, what, two years, and then she died of TB. Then Alexis's son, Peter, became a boy emperor. He didn't last long either. He died of smallpox when he was 14. Then Peter's niece, Anna, became empress for 10 years. And then her baby son, Ivan became emperor for a year. And then finally Peter's daughter, Elizabeth became empress.
哦天哪。正如他所愿，凯瑟琳继位了，但缅希科夫才是俄罗斯真正的统治者。所以他是那个珠光宝气的寡头。珠光宝气的寡头。这种情况又持续了大约两年，然后她死于肺结核。接着，阿列克谢的儿子彼得成了一个少年皇帝。他也没有坚持多久。他14岁时死于天花。然后彼得的侄女安娜当了10年女皇。接着她的小儿子伊凡当了一年皇帝。最后，彼得的女儿伊丽莎白成了女皇。
There's a lot of babies and women there. Send four decades after Peter's death, Russia, which had never been ruled by a woman before was ruled by a woman, a small boy, a woman, a baby, and then a woman. And it's Sophia dead by this point. Yeah, Sophia has gone. I mean, if she weren't, she would have a baby, and then a woman. And is Sophia dead by this point? Yeah, Sophia is gone. I mean, if she weren't, she would have a wry smile on her lips. A wry smile, but also a sense of frustration because she would have probably done a better job than any of them.
那里有很多婴儿和女性。在彼得死后的大约四十年里，这个此前从未由女性统治过的俄罗斯，先后由一个女人、一个小男孩、一个女人、一个婴儿，然后又是一个女人统治。索菲亚到这个时候已经死了吗？是的，索菲亚已经不在了。我的意思是，如果她还在的话，她会露出——一个婴儿，然后是一个女人。索菲亚到这个时候已经死了吗？是的，索菲亚已经不在了。我的意思是，如果她还在的话，她的嘴角会泛起一丝苦笑。一丝苦笑，但也会有一种挫败感，因为她可能比他们中的任何一个都干得更好。
Yeah. But the thing is, I suppose this is testament to Peter's extraordinary achievements that if you'd said this to a Russian in the 1680s or something, this will be the succession. They said, what? Oh, that'll be terrible for Russia. We'll fall apart completely. But of course, even though the faces at the top keep changing, and none of them are quite right, Russia's status is now so established as a great power that it endures. And presumably also the institution of the, of the sardom.
是的。但问题是，我想这证明了彼得非凡的成就，如果你在1680年代左右对一个俄罗斯人说，这就是未来的继承顺序。他们会说，什么？哦，那对俄罗斯来说太糟糕了。我们会彻底崩溃的。但当然，尽管高层的人换了又换，而且没有一个完全合适，但俄罗斯作为大国的地位现在已经如此巩固，以至于它得以长存。大概沙皇制度也是如此。
Exactly. The empire, the emperor or the empress, the autocracy is firmly established. And that's the paradox of Peter's life, isn't it? That he westernizes, but the effect of the westernization is to consolidate the autocracy that had always been traditional in Russia. Yeah, I think that's a really good way of putting it actually, that the very process of modernization, which is so top down, entrenches the power of the autocrats, and the kind of centralization of Russia, and concentrates power even more in the in the capital. And maybe also because he was succeeded by such obviously
没错。帝国、皇帝或女皇、专制统治已经牢固确立。这就是彼得一生的悖论，不是吗？他实行西化，但西化的效果却是巩固了俄罗斯一贯的传统专制。是的，我认为这真是一个很好的表达方式，现代化进程本身就是如此自上而下的，它巩固了专制君主的权力，以及俄罗斯的某种中央集权，并将权力更进一步集中在首都。也许还因为他的继任者显然是
lesser figures, figures, it was easy to dismiss, I guess, that meant that his star, even posthumously burned even more brightly. So that even, you know, a hundred, 150 years later, people still look to Peter as the exemplar as indeed they still do today to some degree. So in her brilliant book about Peter the Great, Lindsay Hughes quotes a pan-Slav historian called Mikhail Pogodin in 1841, one of the great 19th century historians of Russia. And he said, wherever we look, everywhere we encounter that colossal figure, a figure which is still stretching, as it were, his arms over us, and which it seems will never
更平庸的人物，这很容易让人产生一种印象——我想，这使得他的光芒，甚至在死后也燃烧得更加耀眼。以至于即使在一百年、一百五十年后，人们仍然把彼得视为楷模，事实上他们在某种程度上今天仍然如此。因此，琳达·休斯在她关于彼得大帝的杰出著作中，引用了一位名叫米哈伊尔·波戈金的泛斯拉夫主义历史学家在1841年的话，他是19世纪俄罗斯伟大的历史学家之一。他说：“无论我们看向何处，到处都能遇到那个庞大的身影，一个仿佛仍在向我们伸出双臂的身影，而且无论我们在未来取得多大进展，它似乎都永远不会
disappear from sight, no matter how far we advance in the future. And people did subsequently try to downplay him a bit. So if you were really enthusiastic kind of Slavophile, you know, in my orthodoxy and the old ways and stuff, you might distrust Peter as a pro-Western modernizer. The first communist historians tried to downgrade kind of great men and said, oh, he's just a sort of a vehicle for mercantile gentry capitalism. But Stalin invoked him and Vladimir Putin has invoked him. We discussed how Putin has explicitly compared the war in Ukraine with the Great Northern War and compared himself with Peter recapturing what was always Russia's and all of this kind
从视线中消失。”人们后来确实试图稍微贬低他一下。所以，如果你是一个真正狂热的斯拉夫ophile（斯拉夫文化崇拜者），你知道的，坚持我的正统信仰和传统习俗之类的那种人，你可能会把彼得视为一个亲西方的现代主义者而对之不信任。第一批共产主义历史学家试图贬低伟人的作用，说他只是一种商业士绅资本主义的工具。但斯大林召唤过他，弗拉基米尔·普京也召唤过他。我们讨论过普京如何明确将乌克兰战争与大北方战争进行比较，并将自己与彼得相提并论，夺回那些历来属于俄罗斯的东西以及所有诸如此类
of business. What do you make of him, Tom? Well, I mean, he is clearly a Titanic figure in the consequences that his reign has for geopolitics enduring into the present day. He clearly plays a key role in setting up that tension in Russia, which again endures to this day between its kind of Westernizing tendencies and its more traditional tendencies. But also he's the embodiment of why the hope that the process of Westernization, whether it's introducing the enlightenment back in the 18th century or democracy in the wake of the fall of communism, why it never leads to the kind of establishment of state that people in Western
的事情。汤姆，你对他是怎么看的？嗯，我的意思是，他在地缘政治方面对当下产生持续影响的统治，显然是一个泰坦般的人物。他在俄罗斯建立起那种至今仍存在的、介于西欧化倾向与更传统倾向之间的张力方面，显然发挥了关键作用。但同时，他也体现了为什么西化的进程——无论是18世纪引入启蒙运动，还是在共产主义垮台后引入民主——为什么它永远不会带来人们在西欧
Europe and beyond tend to hope for. Because I guess that he serves as an embodiment of everything that makes Russia seem stupendous but also terrifying. Yeah, I think that's fair enough. I mean, I think in many ways there are greatly attractive parts of his character. The curiosity, the energy, the enthusiasm for novelty, you know, the sailing and the love of going to lectures in Holland or in London and stuff. And yet, especially when we've done that final episode, the cruelty, the paranoia, the autocracy,
及其他地区倾向于希望的那种国家体制。因为我猜他成为了所有让俄罗斯看起来既震撼又可怕的事物的化身。是的，我认为这很中肯。我的意思是，在很多方面，他的性格中有极具吸引力的部分。好奇心、活力、对新鲜事物的热情，你知道的，航海，喜欢去荷兰或伦敦听讲座等等。然而，尤其是当我们做完最后一集节目时，残忍、偏执、专制，
they seem so obviously to anticipate the cruelties of Russian history that follow. Well, there are two great bouts of cruelty, aren't there? So there's the Streltsy as well. Yeah, the Streltsy as well. And the truth of the matter is he is a very violent, often angry man. I mean, for me personally, a father who tortures his son to death. I think that's inexcusable. I mean, also I'm very much team Charles the 12th.
它们似乎是如此明显地预示了随之而来的俄罗斯历史上的残忍行径。嗯，有两次大规模的残忍行径，不是吗？所以还有对射击军的处理。是的，还有射击军。事实的真相是，他是一个非常暴力、经常愤怒的人。对我个人而言，一个把儿子折磨至死的父亲。我认为这是不可原谅的。此外，我非常支持查理十二世。
Are you? I wish that he'd won the battle of Poltava. Tom, I don't disagree with you at all. You know I love a Swedish Empire. Anyway, I've quoted a lot a brilliant book on which I've relied very heavily which is Robert K. Massey's biography of Peter the Great which is one of the most capacious and it's incredibly readable swashbuckling story. It's as much about Charles the 12th as it is about Peter.
是吗？我希望他能赢得波尔塔瓦战役。汤姆，我一点也不反对你。你知道我喜欢一个瑞典帝国。总之，我引用了很多我极为依赖的一本杰出著作，那就是罗伯特·K·马西的《彼得大帝传》，这是内容最丰富、极其易读且充满豪侠气概的故事之一。它既是关于查理十二世的，也是关于彼得的。
And I really recommend it. So it seems only fair to end with his very last lines, which I think are beautifully judged. He says of Peter, he was a force of nature and perhaps for this reason, no final judgment will ever be delivered. How does one judge the endless role of the ocean or the mighty power of the whirlwind fabulous Fabulous, Dominic. Thank you so much.
我强烈推荐它。因此，以他最后的话来结束似乎最公平，我认为这些话评价得非常精妙。他这样评价彼得：“他是一种自然力量，也正因如此，人们永远无法做出最终的评判。人们又该如何评判无垠的海洋或狂风的强大力量呢？”太棒了，多米尼克。非常感谢。
And thank you everyone for listening to this Titanic series. We will be back next week with another Titanic figure, Hannibal. So we will see you then. Goodbye. Goodbye. Bye bye. Hi everybody, you're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what?
也感谢大家收听这个伟大的系列节目。我们下周将带着另一个伟大的历史人物——汉尼拔回归。所以我们到时候见。再见。再见。拜拜。嗨，大家好，你们还在。就在节目的最后，我对你们的执着印象深刻。不过听着，我有一个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些节目里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗？
I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that, there is of course only one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC Premier or the many other
我希望这个播客的听众，我希望他们听的是关于我品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你有过这种想法，当然只有一种方法能知道那会是什么感觉。你可以打破广告的常规。你可以成为下一个汇丰银行尊尚客户或许多其他
tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history. And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you were in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest, or indeed your company's interest,
在“余下皆历史”上做过广告的了不起的公司。你可以通过在“余下皆历史”以及高挂网的其他节目上做广告，将你的品牌展示在数百万志同道合的听众面前。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是高挂网。高挂网就是打造这个节目的公司。如果你正盘算着提升你品牌的价值，高挂网非常乐意听到你的声音。你可以登记你的意向，或者你公司的意向，
by going to Goalhanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, Hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在就访问 Goalhanger.com。也就是 Goal (G-O-A-L), Hangar (H-A-N-G-E-R), dot com。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。